So da bin ich, oh ich hör schon Moment Teams hat wieder rum gesteckt.
Habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass Teams einfach extrem sackt, wenn das einfach an den Audio-Settings rumdoktert, ohne dass man das will.
PP Hands. Naja, so groß hat es gar nicht rumgespielt, so, das ist besser.
This device is currently in use. Oh nein. Anzeige ist raus. Warum ist das einfach in use?
Könnte sein, weil ich da gerade reinrede. Möglich, möglich wär's doch. Das ist ja nie.
Moin, kreos, kreos, ich vollgehe da, chaos, kreos, kreos, Krieger, Pogu.
So, Twitch hat noch nicht gecheckt, dass das Stream online ist, das ist nice.
Da braucht Twitch, ist manchmal mega schnell und manchmal übelst langsam.
Hat bestimmt noch ein bisschen was mit der Uhrzeit zu tun, wann man streamt.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt mal warten.
Das ist immer noch kaputt hier unten. Ich muss jetzt mal warten, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass das Stream richtig on ist.
Ja, ich überleg grad, kann ich euch in der Zwischenzeit, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, falls irgendjemand das Wort gucken sollte.
Der kann jetzt ja nicht im Chat schreiben, aber trotzdem, falls jemand ein Wort gucken sollte, kann ich euch irgendwas Spannendes erzählen.
Lass mal kurz überlegen, gibt's irgendwas, womit ich die Zeit überbrücken könnte, bis die Leute da sind, die Notifications bekommen haben.
Moin Fips, gab's irgendwas? Ja, ich hab heute glaube ich die zwei Mal, Leute, ich wurde heute zwei Mal versucht, alleine im Tag, zwei Mal versucht zu fischen.
Zu pfischen, haben sie mich heute versucht zu pfischen.
Und zwar, einmal habe ich eine Fishing-Mail gekriegt, weil ich glaube die eine habe ich auf Twitter gepostet.
Also, obviously, mir hat Unge mal was geschrieben, keine Ahnung, ich würde gerne mein Zeug hier, nein nein, Twitter.
Also, ich habe heute vom legit, vom offiziellen YouTube-Support wieder, von Yavett Raman, habe ich heute vom offiziellen YouTube-Support wieder ein Copyright Warning Strike bekommen.
Legit, mit Sicherheit, also das muss der echte Raman, oder Yavett, ich glaube Yavett ist der richtige Vorname, das muss der echte Yavett Raman vom YouTube-Support sein.
1786, glaub das kann nicht fake sein.
So, also damit wurde ich heute Morgen schon mal versucht zu pfischen und dann habe ich auf der Arbeit noch heute, es ist Premiere, ich habe noch nie eine Fishing-Mail auf der Arbeit bekommen.
Habe ich auf der Arbeit die schlechteste Fishing-Mail aller Zeiten bekommen, die ist wirklich mega schlecht, Moment, aber auf Deutsch, aber auf Deutsch immerhin.
Mist, ich habe die schon gelöscht, mal gucken ob die noch bei mir im Papierkorb, hier, Laura Müller hat mir geschrieben auf der Arbeit, Laura Müller, liebe Grüße von meinem Arbeitsplatz.
Und ich meine auf Deutsch, es war schon ein bisschen gezielteres Fishing und unten drunter ist so ein super verpixeltes Bild, wo steht, hier bin ich übrigens, so ein verpixeltes Bild und dann kann man das anklicken auf einem, passt mal auf, halte euch fest, wetransfer.com Link, legit, seriously, ganz sicher, ganz sicher.
Irgendeine random Laura schickt mir irgendein gefaktes PDF auf wetransfer.com, natürlich, natürlich.
Die Laura vom Wendler, genau die, Moment, heißt die, Moment, heißt die nicht sogar Laura Müller, die vom Wendler?
Ist, heißt sie nicht so? Ich bin ja nicht so im Bild, aber ich glaube, die heißt so, oder? Ja, ich glaube auch, genau, das, das ist, das wird so sein, die hat keinen Bock mehr auf den Wendler und will jetzt DevOps stellzen, das wird sein, Chat, glaube ich auch, glaube auch, ich glaube die Mail ist echt.
Die, die, aber ich muss die Musik, auch wenn es nice ist, ich muss sie ein bisschen leiser machen. Die Playlist kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden, was er machen will. Ja, also zweimal richtig billige Fishing-Mails heute bekommen, obbei das natürlich keine Fishing-Mail ist, das ist bestimmt der echte YouTube-Support, direkt, direkt von Fiverr.
Was trendet denn in Deutschland? Ich will das eigentlich gar nicht wissen, was in Deutschland trendet. Sponsor, Dackel, Traumjob, übergriffig, Wahlsieger, Trump, Gutachter, Deep-Patch, Deep-Patch-Mode, bespricht man die, das ist irgendwie eine Band, Silensky, ich dachte schon immer mit Z und Lehrerin.
Wir hatten, wir hatten in der Berufsschule, ach Mist, ja, vergiss, ich hab das Wort, ich hab das Wort verdreht, aber ich erzähl's jetzt trotzdem mal, damit man sich nicht ganz so bescheuert anhört, was ich erzähle, ich wollte grad sagen, wir hatten eine in der Berufsschule, die hat für ein Erotikportal gearbeitet, als Admin, als Admin, ja, also jetzt nicht falsch verstehen, als Admin.
Und die hat bei Kolleginnen.de gearbeitet. Und irgendwie hab ich bei Lehrerin grad an Kolleginnen gedacht, frag mich nicht, und ist mir das wieder eingefallen. Und was die da teilweise erzählt hat, da fällt's echt vom Glauben, von der Menschheit ab.
Die hat zum Beispiel einmal erzählt, dass die verschiedene, ich muss jetzt gucken, da ich nicht so viele Details erzähle, wir sind hier immerhin auf Twitch, die hat erzählt, dass die irgendwie so eine Tag-Datenbank haben, und dass die Leute dort ihre Videos taggen können, je nach Vorlieben und Fetisch.
Und da hat sie halt mal erklärt so, mit was sie sich auseinandersetzen muss, was sie halt wissen musste, was jeder Tag irgendwie zur richtigen Einordnung, was jeder Tag bedeutet.
Das heißt, die musste dann wirklich sich durchlesen, was die Bedeutung hinter jedem Tag auf so einer Erotikseite ist, hat auch gemeint, also, die war nicht klar, was es alles gibt, und vieles davon will sie eigentlich überhaupt nicht wissen.
Ich auch nicht, ich auch nicht, ja. Aber Admin bei einer Erotikseite möchte ich auch nicht sein.
Da musst du dich, überlegt euch mal, was da für eine Scheiße hochgeladen wird.
Ich mein, ich will auch garantiert nicht Content-Mod auf YouTube, Facebook oder sonst wie sein, da kannst du ja nach einem halben Jahr nur psychische Störungen davon tragen, aber bei einem Erotikportal erst recht auch nicht, weil da wird noch, also da wird vieles abartiges Zeug hochgeladen, was aber noch nicht illegal ist, und dann auch noch freigeschaltet werden muss und so was.
Boah, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Nee, nee, das muss echt nicht sein.
Du hast letztens aus Frankreich eine SMS bekommen, dass ich doch bitte 3,99 Euro Zoll an dir hell überweise, das bekomme ich aber nicht.
Naja, ganz so weit von der Realität weg ist es ja auch nicht, man bekommt ja manchmal vom Zoll irgendwelche Nachrichten, die sind dann aber nicht per SMS aus Frankreich oftmals.
Allerdings, also die schlechtesten Erfahrungen, was das angeht, habe ich tatsächlich mit dem Zoll Schrägschräg DHL in Leipzig gemacht, weil wenn man aus den USA was bestellt, dann landet das höchstwahrscheinlich in Leipzig, weiß ich, ob da so die Hauptabfertigungsstelle ist oder so.
Und die waren so unglaublich langsam und die waren so unglaublich unhilfreich.
Und die Leute am Telefon waren so hilflos, was die gedacht, Mann, wo bin ich da gelandet?
Express, Express Paket, ich habe die extra bezahlt dafür, dass die das abwickeln mit dem Zoll, das hat irgendwie drei oder vier Wochen, ewig hat es gedauert.
Wobei das natürlich nicht, den Zoll musst du beim Paket bezahlen, nee, den Zoll kannst du auch beim Zoll bezahlen, das geht auch.
Ich war auch schon beim Zoll und habe dort direkt was bezahlt, ich habe beim Zoll, ich glaube die Story, gut, dass der Chain noch nicht da ist, da könnte er wieder Recycled, Recycled Story spammen.
Das Highlight bei mir beim Zoll ist gewesen, ich habe mir eine Background-LED-Beleuchtung für den Fernseher bestellt.
Ja, Treme, ist das Treme Light? Nee, Treme, hab vergessen, wie das Ding hieß, hieß doch Treme Light.
Treme Screen, Treme Screen, ich habe mir sowas bestellt, das sind im Endeffekt so Ambilight zum Nachrüsten.
So und in Wirklichkeit sind das LED Strips, man sieht es jetzt, ja hier, guck mal, nee, ja hier, es ist im Prinzip, es ist im Prinzip, ist das eine Steuerung, ist das ein Controller mit LED Strips.
Und ja, also da sieht man es im Endeffekt, es ist ein Controller mit LED Strips gewesen.
Und das ist beim Zoll gelandet, weil es die Amis ja wieder nicht hingekriegt haben, das ordentlich zu deklarieren, ist das beim Zoll gelandet.
Und beim Zoll musste ich dann aufmachen und er hat dann eine Tabelle rausgeholt, was das denn jetzt eigentlich ist.
Weil ich habe ihm erzählt, das ist eine Beleuchtung, das ist eine Hintergrund-LED-Hintergrundbeleuchtung für den Fernseh, ja.
Und dann hat er gemeint so, hm, ok, Fernseh, dann guckt er in seine Tabelle und meint, er sucht dann halt so diese in der Tabelle raus, das für Fernsehgeräte.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, Leute, das Paket war so groß wie ein Xbox-Controller oder so jetzt, nicht sonderlich groß, ja.
Und dann meint er wirklich Fernseh, nein, das ist kein Fernseh, das ist eine Beleuchtung für einen Fernseh, das ist kein Fernsehgerät.
Ja, aber was ist denn das jetzt, das haben wir hier nicht draufstehen. Alter, das war, also der Besuch im Zoll war wirklich negativ Highlight, was ich hatte.
Ich war schon öfters beim Zoll, in letzter Zeit nicht mehr, weil ich mittlerweile weiß, was man machen muss, dass man nicht beim Zoll landet.
Nämlich das Beste ist schon mal nicht aus den USA bestellen. Wenn ihr nicht aus den USA bestellt, das was da heute steht, stimmt nicht.
Wenn ihr schon mal nicht aus den USA bestellt, könnt ihr von ausgehen, das meiste landet nicht beim Zoll, weil die anderen Länder bekommen es irgendwie hin, die Sachen auszuzeichnen.
Nur Bestellungen aus den USA kriegen sie irgendwie nicht gebacken. Ich habe so oft schon bei den China-Chinesen bei AliExpress bestellt, Leute.
Also ich glaube, neben Amazon dürfte eine Zeit lang, also nicht insgesamt, aber eine Zeit lang, dürfte AliExpress meine zweitmeist besuchteste Shopping-Seite gewesen sein.
Nicht in letzter Zeit, in letzter Zeit habe ich tatsächlich relativ wenig bestellt bei AliExpress, aber es gab Zeiten, da habe ich bei AliExpress fast so viel bestellt wie bei Amazon, gerade als ich Elektronik-Kram gebastelt habe.
Und bei denen ist noch nie, ernsthaft noch nie was im Zoll gelandet. Und was witzig ist, die Leute haben immer übelst Probleme, so das kann ich nicht in China bestellen, das landet im Zoll.
Aber bestellen in den USA, wo es sicher im Zoll landet, weil es die Amis nicht gebacken kriegen.
Also eins muss man den AliExpress versendern lassen, entweder schaffen die das gut zu kennzeichnen, sodass es nie beim Zoll landet, oder die haben verschiedene andere Tricks, dass es nicht beim Zoll landet, fragt mich nicht.
Zumindest ist bei AliExpress noch nie bei mir jemals was im Zoll gelandet.
Zumal die es ja auch geschickt machen, die schicken das Ganze ja oftmals aus EU-Warenlagern oder aus Spanien, also oder aus den Niederlanden.
Also ich weiß, AliExpress hatte eine ganze Zeit lang so einen exklusiven Vertrag mit PostNL, mit der niederländischen Post.
Die haben doch da auch irgendwie in Amsterdam oder Rotterdam, Rotterdam wahrscheinlich sind irgendwie die Schiffe angekommen, dann hatten sie teilweise größere Lager in Spanien und ich glaube sie haben jetzt auch im östlichen Europa irgendwas und UK und Frankreich.
Also die sind überall, dann hat sich das natürlich mit Zoll erledigt an der Stelle, für mich als Endverbraucher. Für die nichts.
Ja, so. Ich habe heute einen Ersatzteil von FlexiSpot bekommen, gestern haben sie gesagt, oh geht doch, geht doch.
Ersatzteil, hast du so einen FlexiSpot Tisch, den ich mal vorgestellt habe oder was hast du?
Taugen die was oder würdest du nicht mehr bestellen? Du meinst die DreamLight, du meinst den, ne, DreamScreen? Das meinst du? Hintergrundbeleuchtung?
Die würde ich nicht mehr bestellen, weil die gibt es nicht mehr. DreamScreen ist pleite gegangen.
Es gibt allerdings Alternativprodukte, da weiß ich nicht wie die sind. Ich kann jetzt zum DreamScreen sagen, dass der für ein Gerät aus dem Jahr 2000,
hab das schon eine ganze Weile, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 2014, 2015, ich hab das wirklich schon lang, den Kram.
Gucken, vielleicht hab ich, hab ich ja, hab ich das ja damals auf Twitter geschrieben, ne, ne hab ich nicht.
Okay, also ich hab das, ich hab das schon eine ganze, ganze Weile, also für ein Produkt aus dem Jahr, sagen wir mal so 2015 rum, waren die wirklich gut.
Ich hab das immer noch im Einsatz, funktioniert immer noch. Einzige Problem, was ich habe, meins funktioniert nicht mit, nicht mit 4K.
Und hat Probleme mit HDR. Da gab es zwischenzeitlich neuere Versionen für 4K und HDR. Allerdings kein DreamScreen mehr.
Aber du kannst mal gucken, es gibt jede Menge ähnlicher Ersatz für DreamScreen. Und an sich kann ich wirklich empfehlen, ist mega nice.
Gerade wenn man wie ich im Wohnzimmer, Max FPS.
Wo sieht man mein Wohnzimmer? Mein Wohnzimmer hier, genau, ja ja, hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Man sieht es nicht so wirklich gut, aber ich hab hinter dem Fernseher halt weiße Wand. Das wäre übrigens, wäre übrigens für einen Beamer im Prinzip auch gar nicht schlecht.
Das hab ich mir auch schon überlegt, aber da müssen wir ein bisschen rum basteln, hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Also jetzt sehe ich, ich hab eine weiße Wand, man sieht jetzt nicht, ich hab es zu sehr auf meinem Fernseher gezoomt. Aber man sieht ja im Hintergrund, dass es weiße Wand ist.
Mega schlechte Auflösung, ne? So und da ist das halt wirklich, wirklich cool. Ich weiß, es ist leider zu hell, weiß ich, ob ich hier mal dunkel gemacht hab.
Ein bisschen erkennt man es vielleicht im Hintergrund. Es hat kaum Delay und so, also ich kann es wirklich empfehlen, es ist eine gute Sache.
Auch die Alternativprodukte, wenn die ähnlich sind, würde ich empfehlen, ja.
Wie lange noch DevObstells bis Resturlaub ansteht?
Wahrscheinlich so bis hier, also ungefähr noch eineinhalb Monate, ungefähr noch eineinhalb Monate.
Dann hab ich Resturlaub, so eineinhalb Wochen und dann geht's ab 1. März, geht's los.
Am 1. April geht es im neuen Job los, genau.
Also wie gesagt, ich kann es dir trotzdem empfehlen, guck dir mal die Alternativprodukte an.
An sich ist es eine super Sache, gerade wenn man eine einheitlich gefärbte, ohne großartige Sachen Wand hinter dem Fernseher hat, macht es das viel angenehmer zu gucken.
Ach tatsächlich, ok. Aber es ist gut, dass es dann relativ schnell Ersatzteile gibt.
Dann hab ich doch keine Werbung gemacht für totalen Müll. Ja, das machen wir übrigens nicht.
Ja, so sieht es aus, ansonsten gab es die Woche noch irgendwas spannendes, ich bin gerade am überlegen.
Ich hab heute übrigens auf Twitter, auf Twitter hab ich heute wieder gelernt, wenn man Kritik äußert an einer Programmiersprache.
Was ist denn hier los? Warum geht Nitter nicht? Ist Nitter broken? Was ist da los? Warum ist es kaputt?
Oh, es ist kaputt anscheinend. Twitter, ich hab heute, ich hab heute eine Sache auf Twitter, Twitter hat die API eingestellt.
Nein, ernsthaft, wirklich? Gibt es auch Narrow People Zed? Wir sind, nein, nein, nein, nein. Zedge reicht schon.
Ach, die haben das komplett eingestellt, wirklich? Ok, die kostet was. Ja gut, das können die sich aber nicht leisten.
Das ist ja eine Seite, die kein Geld verdient damit. Die können wahrscheinlich die API Request gar nicht bezahlen.
Der Twitter mich beleidigt hat? Echt, mich hat einer beleidigt im Tweet? Das hab ich gar nicht gesehen. Poste mal, weiß ich gar nicht.
Ne, was ich meine ist, ich hab doch letztens geschrieben, die kostet 150,500 Euro Request.
Das ist ja krass, Alter. Das ist Absicht, oder? Das haben die nicht abgeschafft. Um zu sagen, wir haben sie nicht abgeschafft, aber faktisch hat man sie abgeschafft.
Also, ich hab nach meinem letzten Python-Stream etwas versucht, meine Kritik an der Sprache, die mir so als, das ist nicht übelster Python-Crack,
aber jemand, der das seine Kenntnisse aufgefrischt hat, hab ich mal versucht, in so einem Tweet zusammenzufassen.
Und darauf waren natürlich dann Leute etwas teilweise getriggert, was mich wundert. Man kann auch getriggert sein für Programmiersprachen.
Wobei, das hier wette ich mit euch, das ist Chebat. Das ist Chebat, der meint das nicht ernst. Bei dem bin ich mir zu 99% sicher, dass es Chebat ist.
Allein schon, wie sich das liest. Python noobs at its best. Zen of Python nicht verstanden. Tippe stark darauf, dass du allgemein noch nie an großen Softwareprojekten gearbeitet hast. Geschweige denn, nennenswerte Programmiererfahrung. Arbeite seit 4 Jahren, damit die Verbreitung spricht für sich.
Also, das ist Chebat. Da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Heute hat noch ein anderer geschrieben, den fand ich auch lustig. Also, das hier gar keine Frage. Der hat gesagt, okay, aber ist This jetzt wirklich so viel besser als Self?
Ihr wisst ja, in Java und C-Sharp ist es This, in Python ist es Self. Ist im Prinzip das gleiche.
So, habe ich gesagt, naja, eigentlich ist eher das Problem, dass man das an allen Ecken und Enden in Python nutzen muss. So, und jetzt kommt er. Jetzt, jetzt, ja, habe ich ein Beispiel, also zum Beispiel, Self Punkt underscore underscore nehmen anstatt, anstatt underscore nehmen.
So, und jetzt, und jetzt kommt er. Jetzt kommt er. Der beste, der beste hier. Das ist ein Problem, wenn man versucht, Gewohner von anderen Sprachen auf Python zu übertragen.
Speziell das underscore underscore siehst du in Pythonischem Code praktisch nie. Dazu kann ich nur sagen, der offizielle Style Guide spricht von underscore und underscore underscore.
Der offizielle, also nicht irgendwie so ein Random Dude Auftritt, der offizielle Style Guide, sagt das. Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, es hat mit Self nichts zu tun, weil Self brauchst du immer noch, wenn du auf Klassen, also auf Instanzvariablen referenzieren willst. Ob da jetzt ein Minus Minus oder underscore underscore steht, ist egal.
So, und jetzt kommt aber das Beste. Jetzt kommt aber das Beste. Self weglassen zu können, würde auch nicht zum Konzept von Python passen. Explicit ist better than implicit. Okay, soweit in Ordnung, soweit in Ordnung.
Jetzt kommt's. Mehr Funktional programmieren, dann braucht man nicht so viel selbst. Also sprich auf gut Deutsch. Just don't use it forehead. Oder was, was soll mir denn diese Message jetzt sagen, man? Es ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich mir das ausgedacht, dass ich an der Stelle das ganze OOP Style machen muss.
War halt diese, das ist halt Plugin Module, musste halt so machen. Was ist das für ein Argument? Ja, dann benutzt das halt nicht in der Sprache, dann ist es auch kein Problem.
Ja, nach der Logik könnte man auch sagen, mach doch alles, mach doch alles im Hex Editor, wenn man fehlerfrei programmieren kann, braucht man doch auch sonst keine richtige Programmiersprache. Also mit der Logik kannst du ja alle, also mit dieser nicht Logik kannst du alles irgendwie kontern.
Du brauchst aber trotzdem, ja Moment, in C Sharp macht man das so, da gibt es so eine ungeschriebene Regel, dass man private Instanzvariablen, dass man die Underscore nennt, aber in Python musst du trotzdem Self Punkt schreiben, wenn du auf irgendwelche Instanz Klassen Variablen referenzieren willst.
Also Python ist voll, ist voll mit Selves. Doch doch, in Go gibt es auch sowas, klar gibt es in Go. Heißt das nicht in Go sogar auch Self? Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, zumindest kannst du es in Go nennen wie du willst, du kannst die Klassenreferenz glaube ich in Go auch einfach in eine eigene Variable packen, bin ich mal aus dem Kopf nicht ganz sicher.
Aber sowas gibt es da auch, aber sowas muss es ja im Endeffekt auch geben. Gibt es nicht? Doch das gibt es, warte mal. Ja das stimmt schon, es gibt keine klassen, Self in Go oder? Hier, in Go ist nämlich die Receiver Variable heißt das Ding.
Receivers, Receiver Variables. Boah, boah, meine Augen, ich seh nix.
Receiver, das da meine ich, genau. Also auf sich selbst. Man kann es letztendlich nennen wie man will. Oder das hier? Dafür mach ich zu wenig Go, dass ich euch genau sagen kann welches dieser Dinge ich jetzt. Man kann es in Go aber glaube ich nennen wie man will.
So, ok. Wo ist denn das Problem? Das ist nicht das Problem. Das ist nicht das Problem ob das jetzt Self oder Dis heißt. Das Problem ist dass man in Python so oft, also zumindest das was mir nicht gefällt.
Man kann ja nicht mal sagen, also ich würde nicht mal so weit gehen sagen das ist jetzt irgendwie ein großes Problem. Das ist zwei Sachen. Das ist Gewöhnungssache und das ist persönliche, persönliche Präferenz. Das ist ja eine Sache die man aktuell eh nicht haben darf aber auf das Thema gehe ich extrem nicht ein.
Ja, also zumindest mein Problem bei Python ist nicht dass man This oder Self verwendet sondern dass man zu oft Self verwenden muss. Dass man an jeder Stelle Self benutzen muss.
Ja, der Typ hat vielleicht schon irgendwie den Punkt zu sagen ja das ist halt der Python Style. Das ist schön und gut aber ich finde es trotzdem nervig. Also du musst Sekunde. Wir haben den Kram doch vom letzten Mal glaube ich noch auf.
Ist bei dir schon Chat-GPT am Start? Ja sogar in meiner VM. Mehrfach am Start. So. Guck mal das meine ich. Das meine ich. Also wenn du so private Instance Variable anlegen willst dann macht man das in Python so.
Man sagt Self Punkt. Ich finde es übrigens schon persönlich ein bisschen doof dass man die Dinger hier nicht hier oben irgendwie definieren kann aber ok. Alles Geschmackssache.
So legst du die Dinger an. Self Punkt underscore underscore. Es ist jetzt so egal. Es geht nicht um den underscore. Du kannst es auch so machen ja. Also alles ok.
Das blöde was ich finde ist dass du überall zum überall drauf referenzieren Self brauchst. Guck du brauchst Self Punkt Timer State. Self Punkt. Wenn du Duration aufrufst Self Punkt Duration.
Das finde ich blöd. Also bei Methoden lasse ich es mir irgendwie noch gefallen dass es expliziter ist auf was es sich bezieht. Das mache ich in C-Sharp übrigens auch persönlich ganz gerne dass ich bei internen Methoden aufrufen sage This.
Aber was ich überhaupt nicht mag ist dass man wirklich für alles Self braucht. Ich meine würde man sich da wirklich zu viel ein abbrechen wenn man einfach wenn man einfach so schreiben könnte.
Anstatt Self davor. Gehört halt nicht in den Python Style aber muss mir ja nicht gefallen.
Genau das ist die genau gleiche Taktik ja.
Leute früher oder später. Ich war ich früher oder später. Wir müssen mal wir müssen mal ran. Auch wenn Monika es Monika es ja war angesagt ist.
Aber wir müssen wir müssen mal ran.
Ja genau das ist das so sieht es aus. Das ist das Problem. Ach ja zum Thema Chat-GPT kann ich nur sagen ich habe einmal. Ich habe einmal Chat-GPT in der Kommandozeile. Ich kann hier Sachen fragen wie zum Beispiel Chat-GPT Omega Lul. Was ich funktionieren wird weil garantiert meine Session Timeout ist.
Also ich habe einmal einen Chat-GPT Rapper fürs Terminal. Da kann ich Chat-GPT Sachen fragen wenn meine Session nicht ausgelaufen ist. Aber ich war jetzt ein paar Tage mit der VM nicht mehr. Bestimmt ist meine Session ausgelaufen.
Und ich habe GitHub Code Pilot bei mir in der Shell. Den kann man dann sowas fragen wie How to sync files between servers on Linux. Und der funktioniert in der Regel immer. Ja guck so macht man das.
Der Unterschied zwischen beiden Sachen ist also mal unabhängig davon dass das die Engine ist hinter GitHub Code Pilot und das da oben Chat-GPT. Der Unterschied ist auch der Chat-GPT Rapper ist kostenlos.
Der GitHub Code Pilot Rapper kostet Geld weil du einen API Key brauchst. Das heißt hierfür bezahle ich was pro Abfrage. Aktuell bezahle ich nichts weil man 18 Dollar Startguthaben hat und es in der Beta Phase ist.
Aber das kostet pro API Request und mal gar nicht so knapp. Weil man Pech hat kostet es bis zu 2 Cent pro API Call. Weil was man, ich habe versucht das mal zu erklären weil ich glaube viele haben sich die API Terms noch nicht angeguckt von OpenAI API.
Pricing. Ahja die Seite ist sehr schön. Exzellent. Exzellent. Was ist das? OpenAI Pricing. Was, was bin ich, bin ich hier irgendwas sehen was man nicht sehen sollte oder?
Ich weiss ja nur. Habt ihr jetzt irgendwas gesehen was ich nicht sehen sollte? Was war denn das?
Sehr gut. Es sah aus wie Base64, es war auch Base64 Encoded. Das kann nicht mein API Key gewesen sein weil ich hier nicht eingeloggt bin.
Wenn man sich das Pricing, wenn man sich das Pricing anguckt, vielleicht macht es gerade nochmal, vielleicht ist es dann wieder procken. Wenn man sich das Pricing anguckt was relevant ist hier zum Beispiel Language Models da Vinci oder guckt euch die Language Models an.
Das ist das interessante hier. Also du bezahlst zum Beispiel hier 2 Cent pro 1000 Tokens. Ein Token ist so ungefähr ungefähr ein Wort sagen wir mal. Steht ja hier auch glaube ich.
You can think of those pieces of words. Also sag mal so ungefähr ein Token ist ein Wort ungefähr. Die Sache ist nur die, dass du nicht nur deine Anfrage bezahlst.
Also mal angenommen du möchtest hier diesem Language Model eine Anfrage stellen. Warum steigert Prime Subscription bei Wublaws den IQ? Willst du die fragen?
Das ist nicht das was du bezahlst. Du bezahlst deine Anfrage zumindest habe ich das so verstanden. Du bezahlst deine Anfrage plus den Prompt und der Prompt ist das was dem Language Model sagt wie es sich verhalten soll.
Das heißt der Prompt ist quasi die Konfiguration für das Language Model. Das heißt du musst erstmal einen Prompt hinschicken um das Language Model zu konfigurieren dass es sich so verhält wie du möchtest.
Und da kannst du zum Beispiel Prompt kannst du so einem Language Model oder kannst du der AI beispielsweise sagen du bist du bist ein Linux Terminal oder sowas in der Richtung.
Und dementsprechend musst du das konfigurieren plus deine Anfrage schicken. Das heißt das ist deutlich mehr als deine Anfrage was du bezahlen musst. Da steht 750 Wörter pro 1000 Tokens.
Ja ich sag doch ungefähr kannst du das in Wörtern rechnen. Also kannst du ungefähr sagen du brauchst einen Prompt plus deine Anfrage und je nachdem wie der Prompt geschrieben ist die sind auch mal gerne ein bisschen länger dass man gescheiter Antworten bekommt.
Dann bezahlst du so ungefähr ja wenn du Pech hast pro Anfrage ungefähr zwei Cent. Also dementsprechend ist der Gramm halt auch immer verfügbar und sonst wie aber kostet auch Geld.
Und ChatGPT selber ja meine Session ist ausgelaufen ChatGPT selber kostet nichts über den Rapper. Ist beides ganz praktisch und wisst ihr wofür ich ChatGPT tatsächlich ganz gut finde.
Leute ich lock mich ich muss ich muss euch mal kurz ausblenden. Ich lock mich mal kurz ein und dann zeige ich euch wofür ich das wofür ich das wirklich ganz ganz nice finde.
Ich hoffe ich weiß. ChatGPT ist at capacity now. Okay wir können uns nicht einloggen.
Nope no pass. ChatGPT ist ausgelassen gerade. Na gut dann lassen wir es bleiben.
Also wie gesagt wofür ich ChatGPT wirklich mag ist sowas zum Beispiel dass man das man ich habe es nicht mehr.
Das finde ich nice. Das ist manchmal verkehrt aber zum größten Teil ist es ist die Antwort gut und die ist oftmals schneller und besser als wenn man sich die Parameter selbst über die Mainpage zusammensucht.
Was natürlich noch besser ist für Commandos die unterstützt sind ist wenn das nicht kennt ich zeige das mal. Explain Shell ist Poggers.
Explain. Die Seite ist wirklich nice wie es wirklich da ist. Ja hier kriegste hier kriegste auch das ist quasi so ein Rapper für die Mainpage wenn du so willst bloß dass es dir das die einzelnen Sachen erklärt.
Okay es ist übrigens gar nicht Minus Minus Info Info Poggers. Die Seite die Seite ist auch wirklich wirklich cool. Explain Shell gibt bestimmt auch irgendeine Konsolen Plugin Integration.
Welches Theme das ist für ZSR. Das ist Starship allerdings nicht in der Default Konfig. Und zwar meine Dot Files gibt es noch nirgends wo weil ich übelst voller Sack bin und nichts hochlade.
Aber ich euch schon seit irgendwie gefühlt zwei Wochen versprochen habe dass ich was hochlade. Also der Prompt ist das hier Starship und ich bin einfach auf Presets gegangen die irgendwo hier stehen.
Presets. Und ich habe dieses Preset genommen M365 in die Pastel Power Line basiert auf M365 Prinzess. Was Name. Und das habe ich für mich angepasst.
Ich habe zum Beispiel wie man hier sieht. Wie man hier sieht ich habe die Farbe Hornweiß oder von diesem komischen Grau was es ist umgestellt auf meinen Shell Hintergrund.
Und ich habe noch ein paar andere Sachen hinzugefügt zum Beispiel wenn man jetzt in ein.NET Projekt reingeht dann sieht man.
Also neben den Standardsachen die drinnen sind sieht man jetzt auch ausführlichere Git Infos die sind standardmäßig nämlich in dem Preset auch noch drinnen.
Und man sieht welche.NET Version aktuell bei mir installiert ist und man sieht welche.NET Version also global systemweit und welche.NET Version das jeweilige Projekt als Target hat.
Habe ich noch zusätzlich eingestellt und ich habe einen 2 Zeilen Prompt draus gemacht anstatt einen 1 Zeilen Prompt. Weil wie man hier schon sieht stellt euch mal vor das wäre ein 1 Zeiliger Prompt.
Dann wäre mein Cursor jetzt hier. Dann würde ich jetzt quasi immer auf die rechte Hälfte von meinem Bildschirm gucken und hätte hier kaum Platz.
Also hier in der Zeile kann ich nichts Sinnvolles mehr schreiben. Deswegen bin ich ein Fan von 2 Zeilen Prompt. Ist ein bisschen Geschmackssache.
Ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist Chat. Könnt ihr mal schreiben ob ihr eher 2 Zeilige oder 1 Zeilige Prompt mögt. Aber ich mag 2 Zeilige Prompt.
Gerade aus dem Grund weil das immer an der gleichen Stelle ist wo man schreibt. Und heutzutage ist der Bildschirm auch groß genug. Muss man sich keine Gedanken machen deswegen.
Das heißt ich habe die Standard Vorlage hier genommen und habe das angepasst zu dem Zeug hier. So sieht es aus. Exzellent.
Alter ich freue mich schon auf meine neue Heim Server Hardware. Eine dicke übertrieben. Ja du hast extrem dicke übertrieben.
Die Sache ist nur die. Du brauchst wahrscheinlich die Leistung nicht. Aber wenn man Kohle hat ist doch alles nice.
Jetzt kommen bestimmt viele Leute und sagen ja aber der Stromverbrauch. Nee nee aktuelle Hardware ist relativ gut was Stromverbrauch angeht.
Also das Ding kann übertrieben viel Strom fressen Leute. Ich sag euch also wenn er die Kiste hier auf volle Leistung prügelt.
Dann ist er bestimmt bei 5, 5, 600 Watt allein schon CPU und restliche Hardware.
Aber im Eidl wird das Ding trotzdem nicht nicht bedeutend über 20 verbrauchen.
Also ich weiß ja nicht wie viele HDDs und SSDs da dran hängen. Aber wahrscheinlich wird das Ding je nachdem wie die restliche Hardware ist wahrscheinlich nicht über 20, 30 Watt Eidl verbrauchen.
Eher 20. Also insofern ist das gar keine schlechte Wahl. Es ist halt wahrscheinlich etwas übertrieben. Aber kann man machen. Warum nicht?
Verwendet ihr an der Arbeit einen Service Match wie ist... Nein machen wir nicht.
Ich hab letztens danach geguckt was es ist. Ich hab es aber schon wieder vergessen. Ehrlich gesagt.
Was ist denn das? Istdio? Simplify observable traffic management security and policy with leading Service Match.
Ok ich hab das jetzt gelesen. Ich hab immer noch keine Ahnung was es ist. Was ist es denn? What is Istdio? Discover House Service Match Helps.
Ist das im Prinzip sowas wie Container Orchestrierung? Also ernsthaft anhand der Beschreibung kann ich mir jetzt nicht so viel vorstellen.
Istdio addresses the challenging developers and operators face with a distributed or microservice architecture.
Whether you are building from scratch or migrating existing applications to cloud native. Istdio can help. Ich hab seriously keine Ahnung was es macht.
Discovery Configuration Certificates. Es ist ein bisschen Richtung Cloud Container Orchestrierung oder sowas. Keine Ahnung was es ist und ich kann dir zumindest sagen dass wir es nicht einsetzen.
Kann ich alles kennen. Das wichtige ist wenn man jetzt feststellt es ist eine gute Lösung für ein Problem was man hat dass man sich das relativ schnell angucken kann.
Das ist ja das worauf es in der IT heutzutage ankommt. Nicht alles kennen aber sich so gut genug auskennen. Man kann durchaus eine Spezialgebiete haben. Das ist ja letztendlich auch das wofür man fette Stonks Bezahlung kriegt.
Aber wichtig ist auch dass man drum herum genug kennt dass man sich in neue Sachen schnell einarbeiten kann. Und da hilft oftmals auch sich in einem Gebiet besonders tiefgreifend auszukennen.
Klingt jetzt doof weil man sagen würde hey was bringt es mir wenn ich mich in ein Gebiet auskenne mich in das andere einzuarbeiten.
Aber ich hab schon oft gemerkt dass man viele Sachen an Konzepten und sonst wie trotzdem transferieren kann.
Auch wenn es unterschiedliche Themengebiete sind und sei es nur die Art und Weise wie man sich in irgendwas einarbeitet.
Also neue Sachen lernen können möglichst schnell. Also beste Google Skills. Das ist auch was ich jedem Azubi immer erzählt habe wir haben ja leider aktuell keine.
Das ist das wichtigste was sie brauchen.
Kannst ja mal das Programm in ZSelf schauen was weniger ZSelf hat. Das ZSelf Programm hat. Easy weniger ZSelf. Weil du kein ZSelf schreiben musst um private Variablen zuzugreifen.
Das ist was das interessiert mich persönlich überhaupt nicht. Er schreibt ich mag es an Python gar nicht dass die Klammern fehlen. Ich finde das macht den Code viel unübersichtlicher.
Das stört mich zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht. Ja das finde ich auch ein bisschen lächerlich. Aber das stört mich beispielsweise überhaupt nicht.
Ich finde das vom Ansatz her mit den Eindrückungen gar nicht mal so doof. Es hat ein paar Nachteile.
Doch ZServers wollen wir uns auch anschauen. ZServers ist auf jeden Fall auf Programm. Ich schreibe mir das mal auf.
Gucken wir uns auf jeden Fall an. Aber nicht heute. Heute bin ich zu sehr im Arsch.
Es hat ein paar Nachteile. Natürlich werden jetzt wahrscheinlich die Python-Kenner wieder kommen und sagen Max das liegt gar nicht daran.
Gut dann würde mich aber die Begründung interessieren woran es dann liegt.
Ich glaube es gibt ein Problem was Python mit den Eindrückungen hat die nicht mit den Eindrückungen jetzt wirklich selbst zusammenhängen sondern mit dem Parsing.
Habt ihr euch zum Beispiel schon mal gefragt warum es in Python nicht möglich ist eine Multiline Lambda Expression zu machen.
Also warum es in Python nicht möglich ist. Boah man. Alter meine Augen. Eine anonyme Funktion als Parameter zu übergeben die länger als eine Zeile ist.
Das ist eine abartige Syntax finde ich. Allein schon dass man so ein Keyword davor schreiben muss.
Und es ist auch maximal möglich einzeilig hier dahinter zu schreiben.
Also was ich in Dortnet zum Beispiel machen kann ist sowas wie List Punkt Sort. Ich weiß das gibt es da nicht aber sagen wir mal.
Oder sagen wir mal was weiß ich. Where. Oder Filter. Filter. Filter. F. Blupf. Keine Ahnung. Blah Blah Blah Blup. Blup Blup Blup.
Return. Lulve. So. Das kann ich in sich scharf machen. Du musst das hinten dran machen für Multiline. Ja Moment Moment.
Wenn ich den Backslash hinten dran mache dann ist es ja nicht wirklich Multiline und kann dann auch keine Sachen machen was eine zweite Zeile erfordert.
Es ist eine einzelne Zeile umgebrochen in mehrere Zeilen. Das ist ja was anderes.
So und in Python musst du sowas hier machen dann quasi. List Punkt Filter. Lambda. Blupf. Ne ne ne. Warte mal. X. X ist es so glaube ich ne. Blup Blah Blah. So du kannst du kannst hier keine Zeilen.
Du kannst hier nichts. Nichts. Nichts Multilinemäßig machen. So und ich gehe ganz stark davon aus.
Das liegt daran weil sie Probleme haben den Paser für solche Ausdrücke zu erweitern. Wann es anfängt und wann es aufhört gescheit.
Durch die Einrückung. Das sage ich jetzt einfach mal ohne jemals am Python Interpreter oder sonstige gearbeitet zu haben.
Das ist was was mir in meinem Bauchgefühl sehr naheliegend erscheint. Ich weiß nicht ob es wirklich daran liegt.
Aber wenn nicht würde mich interessieren woran es dann liegt dass es nicht möglich ist.
Natürlich die super krassen Fanboys die werden jetzt sagen ja das liegt daran weil es nicht notwendig ist.
Für alles was länger ist als eine Zeile kann man doch einfach eine extra Funktion definieren.
Ja man kann sich das alles immer irgendwie schön reden aber es hat sicherlich seinen Grund was sich die Language Designer dabei gedacht haben.
Warum sie sowas naheliegendes nicht machen. Alternativen gibt es immer.
Wie gesagt wenn wir alle perfekt wären und wenn die Welt ganz toll wäre.
Dann würden wir alle mit Hexeditor fehlerfrei beinahe Programme schreiben die super krass und schnell und fehlerfrei sind.
Ist aber nicht so. Und ich gehe davon aus dass es nur einseitig möglich ist liegt mit unter anderem daran weil sie Probleme haben das in den Paser einzubauen.
Wegen den Einrückungen. Also ich habe überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit den Einrückungen an sich.
Die finde ich sogar ganz gut. Das sehen wir auch das was die Sprache mit auszeichnet.
Aber es gibt so ein paar andere Sachen die mir auf den Keks gehen.
Ja ich weiß ich weiß.
Ja demnächst müssen wir uns Kotlin angucken also Java.
Hecke.
Bingen hat Chat GPT doch nun auch integriert.
Total Request per Month.
Alter ist das teuer die Twitter API.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Man kommt doch auch als größerer. Also mal angenommen man hat irgendeinen Service der die Twitter API nutzt.
Mit 10.000 10.000 Request im Monat. Das ist doch nichts.
10.000 Request in der Stunde. Ja vielleicht. Okay.
Aber doch nicht im Monat.
Und was wollen die dafür.
2500.
Das ist doch komplett lächerlich.
Stimmt das denn.
Ist das denn richtig was sie da gepostet haben.
Twitter API Pricing.
Alter warum ist das.
Mensch so hell.
Okay.
Premium.
Tweets per Request. Ach die man fetschen kann.
Also.
Das ist unsinnig teuer.
Das ist doch wirklich uns unsinn.
Das wird doch keiner freiwillig benutzen.
Ja super damit haben sie auf einen Schlag.
Alle aber komplett alle Third Party Clients gekillt.
Also Web Services. Was natürlich noch geht den Desktop Clients oder so.
Die sich ja mit User Account einloggen. Das wird das wird funktionieren.
Damit haben sie auf einen Schlag einfach mal komplett das gesamte.
Third Party Ökosystem gekillt.
Was mit Sicherheit Absicht war.
Ja habe ich beantwortet oder habe ich ja gesagt.
Custom Konfig von diesem Standard Preset.
Jemand anderes wurde beleidigt.
Das ist auf Twitter ja normal das Leute beleidigt werden.
Ich meine war die die letzten paar Tage.
War die letzten paar Tage mal auf Twitter.
Ich glaube ich habe noch nie und ich bin schon lange auf Twitter.
Ich habe noch selten einen so großen wie kann man es nennen.
Circle Jerk was auch immer.
Er lebt auf Twitter wie die letzten Tage.
Mann Alter ging es da ab.
Da sind die Fetzen geflogen.
Wegen dem Wizard Game.
Das war echt absoluter Wahnsinn wieder auf Twitter.
Die Leute sind wieder komplett eskaliert.
Alle haben ausflippen gewesen.
Das ist ja immer noch nicht vorbei.
Die flippen ja immer noch aus.
Hast du schon mal Linux Mint genutzt?
Wenn ja was sagst du dazu?
Möchte auf der Arbeit auf Linux wechseln?
Weiß nicht so ganz welche Linux ich nehmen soll.
Linux Mint ist super einsteigende Distribution.
Kann man sich nicht drüber beschweren.
Also kann ich dir wärmstens ans Herz legen Linux Mint zu verwenden.
Mir persönlich gefällt der Mate Desktop von Mint am besten.
Das liegt aber auch daran weil ich auf minimalistische Desktop
und minimalistische Oberflächen stehe.
Oder minimalistischer.
Deswegen entweder ist es bei mir XFCE Mate oder Fluxbox oder sowas.
Oder halt das was ich immer benutze i3.
Aber Linux Mint in Kombination mit allen der Desktop kannst du eigentlich kaum was falsch machen.
Letztendlich ist es, wobei ist es überhaupt noch Ubuntu based oder ist es Debian based mittlerweile?
Haben die nicht umgeschwenkt auf Debian based?
Das war mal Ubuntu.
Haben die nicht umgeschwenkt auf...
Ich muss hier auch einen Darkreader installieren.
Ich stehe hier ab.
Based on Debian and Ubuntu.
Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Verstehe.
Ja kann ich dir empfehlen.
Ich würde vorher nochmal klären ob das in Ordnung geht dass du selbstständig Linux auf deinem Arbeitsrechner installierst.
Weil vielleicht gehen ja manche Sachen nicht die sich die Firma vorstellt.
Die gehen sollen.
Vielleicht benutzt ihr irgendwelche Windows Desktop Software.
Vom Passwort safe bis zu sonstigen internen Dingen die nur unter Windows gehen.
Und ob die Firma damit einverstanden ist dass du damit deinen Rechner effektiv aus ihrem AD und ihrer Verwaltung raus nimmst.
Wenn die damit kein Problem hatten das erlaubt kann ich dir Linux Mint ans Herz legen.
Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Okay alles klar jetzt ist eh vorbei.
Ja ist wirklich nice.
Macht Stats eins? Ist das Summary?
Okay da Mark schreibt ich benutze es.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit Kreisangestellte, das geht wahrscheinlich um Mint.
Hauptsächlich weil das Meister an Anwendungen bei uns goes mit Ticketsystem, Informationsportalen und bin komplett auf Windows nicht angewiesen.
Da PDF Verarbeitung auch mittlerweile im Browser möglich brauche ich auch den Adobe Stellz nicht mehr.
Ah das ist gut.
Da hast du Glück.
Ich habe mittlerweile auf der Arbeit ist für mich so gelöst ich habe ein offizielles Windows Notebook.
Wo ich den ganzen Corporate wahnsinn drauf machen kann den man da so braucht.
Und ein Linux Notebook, ein Surface Book das finde ich wirklich nice.
Das einzig dumme ist das ist so minimalistisch das den Deckel nicht richtig auf kriegst.
Früher stell euch vor es gab früher bei Laptops am Deckel so einen kleinen Schalter oder zumindest sowas so eine kleine Einbuchtung am Deckel.
Das man den Deckel einfacher aufmachen kann.
Mittlerweile sind die Dinge aber so krass designt und stylish und Lack glatt.
Das es selbstverständlich keine Einkerbung oder irgendwelche Sachen gibt und du die Fingernägel brauchst um dein Notebook öffnen zu können.
Aber so ist das.
2023 geht Design eindeutig über gute Anwendung.
Ansonsten ist das Surface Book aber wirklich nice.
Habe das mit dem minimalistischen Window Management noch nie so richtig hinbekommen nutze ich jetzt einfach Gnome Autofill.
Kannste machen.
Ich persönlich ihr kennt mich ihr wisst das.
Ich benutze eigentlich so gut wie immer i3 solang es möglich ist.
Solange ich da selbst die Hoheit drüber habe.
I3 ist für mich die optimale Kombination weil ich mag nichts anderes an Linux desktops.
Was noch am ehesten geht ist wirklich sowas wie Mate oder XFCE oder Fluxbox.
Wenn es ein richtig kompletter Desktop mit Fenstern und Geschiss sein muss.
Ich mag i3.
Und ich mag i3 aus dem einzigen Grund nicht weil ich unbedingt Tiling Window Manager haben will oder sonst was.
Wobei das schon ein bisschen damit zusammen hängt.
Ich mag i3 aus dem einzigen Grund weil i3 einfach da ist ohne irgendwie im Weg zu sein.
An i3 gibt es eigentlich kaum was was es überflüssig noch darüber.
Guck mal selbst diese Leiste hier oben ist nicht von i3.
Das einzige was von i3 ist ist tatsächlich die drei Desktop Icons hier oben.
Und diese drei Workspace Icons oder die bis zu neun möglichen Workspace Icons.
Und ja diese ganzen Tastatur Shortcuts wie Umschalt und sonst wie was.
Und ein bisschen wenn ich es wirklich haben will Window Management oder Tiling Management ist von i3.
Der Rest ist andere sonst nicht i3.
Also i3 ist so schön minimalistisch deswegen mag ich gerne benutze ich gerne i3.
Gibt gibt noch mehr Alternativen dazu muss muss nicht i3 sein aber i3 ist so.
i3 ist quasi der Mainstream Tiling Window Manager.
Woher ist denn die Leiste das ist Bumblebee Status.
Guck mal wir können den selbst programmierten Timer jetzt mal auschecken hier.
Gucken ob der gleich aus Timert.
Hallo zusammen sagte Gustl.
Oder ist es Gust I Twitch.
Hallo zusammen ich habe auf der Arbeit ein kleines Problem wir haben eine SQL Tabelle.
Wenn mich einer triggern will würde jetzt sagen eine SQL Tabelle.
Kennt ihr die Leute die nicht SQL sagen sondern SQL.
Wobei ich da auch schon mehrere mehrere Aussprachen von gehört habe.
Wir haben eine SQL Tabelle.
Mit vier Terabyte Daten das ist ganz schön viel.
Und es werden mehr darüber gibt es einige Reports deren Abfragen manchmal 30 Minuten benötigen.
Total inakzeptabel ja das verstehe ich.
Und da habe ich die Aufgabe diese Reports zu verbessern.
Dass quasi instant ein Ergebnis kommt.
Ich dachte ihr dann eine MongoDB zu packen was würde ihr hier machen.
Okay ich habe Seriously keine Ahnung was ihr mit eurer Datenbank macht.
Und ich bin auch kein Datenbank Optimierung Experte.
Aber es gibt trotzdem ein paar Sachen die mir einfallen.
Das erste ist man kann Postgres irgendwie partitionieren.
Frag mich nicht wie das genau funktioniert.
Das zweite ist kannst du die Dinger nicht im voraus irgendwie generieren.
Also dass du zum Beispiel nicht jedes mal alles zusammen rechnen musst.
Sondern schon während die Daten erstellt werden anfängst zusammen zu rechnen.
Nee nicht Cache.
Nee das meine ich nicht.
Also du könntest doch.
Also ich habe ja keine Ahnung wie das wie das jetzt aussieht.
Ja aber sagen wir mal es werden alle User Requests gelockt.
Was wahrscheinlich DSGVO, TOS ist aber gehen wir mal.
Es werden User Requests gelockt.
Und du möchtest quasi wissen.
Wie in einem Report wie viele User Requests es gegeben hat im Monat.
Du könntest ja ein extra Feld anlegen.
Wie nennt man das in der Tabelle?
Extra Feld?
Keine Ahnung.
Du könntest ja ein extra Feld anlegen.
Oder irgendwie so eine Summary Tabelle machen.
Wo du beispielsweise einmal hochzählst pro User Request.
Also sprich dass das dann nur noch aus dieser Tabelle abgefragt werden muss.
Für den Report.
Und nicht für den Report jedes mal frisch zusammen gerechnet werden muss.
Kann ChatGPT nicht fragen weil meine Session Timeout ist.
Und ich mich gerade nicht einloggen kann weil es überlastet ist.
So viel als jemand der keine Ahnung fand.
Das ist nicht off Topic.
Solche Sachen sind genau richtig bei mir auf Twitch.
Ich habe dazu einfach keine Ahnung.
Aber ich weiß dass wir im Chat einige Leute haben die Ahnung haben.
Und deswegen passt hier schon richtig gut hin.
Mehr kann ich dir dazu auch nicht sagen.
Weil ich da Datenbank technisch jetzt nicht so den Wahnsinn.
Also noch ein zweites Datenbank System dazu zu packen halte ich jetzt erst mal für nicht so sinnvoll.
Das würde ich vermeiden.
Ich weiß nicht ob dir ein Index wirklich was bringt an der Stelle.
Ein Index ist ja gut wenn du.
Also Leute Datenbank und ich ihr wisst das ist nicht mein Fachgebiet ist ja.
Ein Index ist ja in der Regel doch denke ich nur gut wenn du auf was.
Wenn du schnell auf eine.
Wie heißt das eine Row.
Wie heißt das bei Datenbank.
Also wenn du schnell auf Einträge zugreifen willst.
Über was anderes als den Primary Key.
Aber wenn du trotzdem wissen willst.
Wie viele Anfragen gab es im letzten Monat.
Dann musst du die Dinger ja alle rausziehen und zählen es sei denn du hast im Vorfeld schon irgendwie zusammengefasst.
Beispiel 2 ist bei jedem nicht fest.
Jetzt kommt das Sariks und sagt Chat GPT ist sehr gut.
Ich glaube das sind so Sachen wo der Chat GPT auch nur so allgemeines Zeug erzählt.
Ach so na dann ist ja gut.
Das machen wir übrigens immer noch nicht.
Selbstverständlich werden die Open AI verkaufen.
Die verkaufen Open AI ja schon.
Du kannst ja jetzt schon AP.
Pricing und alles einsehen.
Und du kannst glaube ich jetzt auch schon kaufen.
Die werden das verkaufen.
Die werden das genauso verkaufen wie GitHub Code Pilot was ja übrigens auch Open AI ist.
Die ist garantiert 100 prozentig.
Also gibt es gibt es ja seit ein paar Tagen genau gibt es seit ein paar Tagen schon Premium.
Please Smile Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Sorry Leute falls ich irgendjemand vergessen habe.
Hypersoft encryption hier.
Du hast auch gar nichts verpasst.
Neustart schreist Squal für SQL.
Das wird ja immer schlimmer.
Panda 2 Dankeschön für den Sub.
Cloud Native Menschen würden wahrscheinlich viel sagen wenn er taglang ist.
Also allein schon dass er überhaupt noch eine Self Hosted Datenbank hat geht ja gar nicht.
Das ganze muss zumindest in irgendein Cloud Service.
Und dann drüber zugegriffen wird dann auch nur über irgendwelche.
Wie heißt das bei Microsoft Web App Functions und Web Apps.
Und die Reports selbstverständlich nur über Azure Functions.
Generiert.
Was eventuell vielleicht auch noch in Ordnung geht ist wenn du den Managed Kubernetes Cluster bei Azure kaufst.
Um dort eine Anwendung noch drauf zu deployen.
Aber ich glaube das ist immer noch nicht immer noch nicht Passwort genug für richtig krasse Cloud Native Menschen.
GPC abfragen ne das ist das ist auch nicht Cloud Native genug.
Cloud Native wer was wäre das keine Ahnung.
Bin ich anscheinend nicht Cloud Native genug für.
Gibt es schon Blockchain Datenbank klar.
Albino geil Dankeschön für den Zap.
Er wird jetzt grundsätzlich sein Datenbank Aufbau ja nicht mehr inkompatibel ändern können oder.
Ich meine sie haben vier Terabyte Daten da drinnen.
Da schmeißt du nicht mal kurz alles über den Haufen.
Ich meine eine Sache eine Sache die mir einfällt.
Die unabhängig von der Datenbank geht die aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht die sinnvollste Lösung ist.
Also eine Sache die mir aus Entwicklersicht einfällt die man machen könnte ist du kannst einfach faken.
Du weißt ja wahrscheinlich wann das Reports also wie die Reports aussehen oder was in die Reports rein muss.
Du lässt die Reports einfach einmal pro Nacht generieren.
Und wenn eine Anfrage kommt lieferst du in den letzten Reporte aus.
Dann ist auch scheiß egal ob das eine halbe Stunde dauert weil nachts um um 3.75.
3.75 um 3.75 generiert interessiert das kein mehr.
Dann juckt es nicht und dann kann dann irgendjemand aus dem Vorstand kommen unseren krassen Report generieren.
Aber das geht innerhalb von zwei Sekunden weil der Report schon pregeneratet ist.
Ja genauso was in der Rechnung euch auch gerade überlegt.
Okay jetzt kommen die ganzen HLQ Datenbank Leute.
Kommt mal ein Video zu OpenAI ChatGPT.
Ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll großartig weil ChatGPT YouTube ist voll damit.
Es hat jeder schon was zu gesagt.
Es wurde mehr oder weniger alles dazu gesagt.
Es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich ein wahnsinnig großer OpenAI User bin.
Klar ich habe das auch schon ausprobiert wir haben es hier im Stream schon ab und zu gemacht.
Ich benutze GitHub CodePilot.
Ich habe auch schon im Stream Sachen abgefragt aber ich weiß nicht was ich großartig dazu erzählen soll.
Ich meine dass es Entwickler überflüssig machen wird halte ich für Blödsinn.
Genauso wie das uns Lowcode Tools demnächst an die Manager alles programmieren und du keinen Entwickler mehr brauchst.
Das glaube ich alles nicht.
Ich gehe davon aus dass Technologien wie ChatGPT in Zukunft auch im Alltag vermehrt eine Rolle spielen werden.
Zumal sie heute schon sehr hilfreich sein können.
Ich sage nur YouTube Clickbait Titelgenerator oder solche Geschichten.
Oder solche Tools wie Jim schreibt dir eine Mail und du hast gerade keinen Bock auf den.
Und du sagst dann irgendeine AI sagt Jim er soll die Fresse halten aber das auf net.
Und Copy Paste ist das dann in die E-Mail sowas.
Also es gibt schon ein paar ganz coole und sinnvolle Anwendungen.
Man merkt aber dass vieles noch ziemlich in der Findungsphase ist.
Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel Tools wie das Ding Home App oder so.
Das ist das erste was mir einfällt.
Das ist ein Service damit kannst du quasi Präsentationen generieren aus einem Thema.
Wobei man halt wirklich sagen muss das was da an Präsentationen rauskommt.
Das sieht hier auf dieser Vorstellungsseite viel cooler aus als es in Wirklichkeit ist.
Also dem Ding gibst du einen Titel und dann generiert es dir einen Text für deine Slides.
Und generiert auch Bilder dafür.
Das was da rauskommt darüber kannst du aber ehrlich gesagt damit keine Präsentation halten.
Du kannst auch ganz auf Rewrite drücken und sowas.
Es mag vielleicht sinnvoll sein als Ergänzung.
Und das ist das wo ich in Zukunft auch das meiste noch der ganzen AI Geschichten sehe.
Zumindest das was man so im täglichen Arbeitsablauf oder täglichen Benutzen im Einsatz hat als Unterstützung.
Wo ich mir das zum Beispiel durchaus vorstellen kann sowas als Art Powerpoint plugin zu haben.
Wenn dir gerade nichts selbst einfällt.
Weil du weißt okay so ¼ Stunde Präsentation.
Du weißt vielleicht auch ungefähr was du sagen willst.
Aber du hast jetzt gerade keine gute Idee wie du dieses eine Subthema irgendwie in deine Präsentation packen willst.
Du fragst mal die AI und hast dann vielleicht dadurch ein bisschen Inspiration was du machen könntest.
Das ist alles sinnvoll.
Dass es Programmierer überflüssig machen wird.
Dass es Grafikdesigner überflüssig machen wird.
Oder dass es Illustrator Leute überflüssig machen wird.
Oder Grafikdesigner und sowas blödsinnig.
Das wird erstmal nicht passieren.
Naja also ich kenne jemand.
Ich habe vor kurzem vor zwei Tagen oder drei Tagen habe ich mit einem zusammen ein bisschen.
Das hat sich so ergeben.
Wir haben ein bisschen Bewerbung für ihn zusammen geschrieben im Discord.
Und da haben wir tatsächlich AI verwendet dabei.
Hauptsächlich DeepL um die Sache zu übersetzen.
Beziehungsweise ein bisschen Inspiration für die Übersetzung zu holen, weil die Bewerbung gab es in Deutsch und in Englisch.
Und bei manchen Sachen haben wir uns gefragt.
Hä?
Das wird doch Sonny Kyle nie jemand auf Englisch schreiben.
Oder umgedreht manchmal haben wir die Sachen auf Deutsch übersetzt.
Dann haben wir gesagt das wird doch so niemand auf Deutsch schreiben.
Für solche Sachen, für sowas ist das wirklich nice.
Aber ich glaube es muss keiner wirklich Angst um seinen Job haben.
Dass demnächst AI das übernehmen wird.
Also im kreativen Bereich.
Und Axis.
Also wer irgendwelche Produktivsysteme auf Axis Basis betreibt, der hat eh glaube ich die Kontrolle über sein Leben verloren.
Weil ich das wahrscheinlich nicht sagen sollte, weil es viel mehr produktiv eingesetzte Axis Systeme gibt als man vermutlich hält.
Kann man gleich gucken.
Jetzt eine Playlist für die Musik.
Top 50 Mario Songs of All Time von Enrico Top Lists.
Es gibt bestimmt Blockchain Daten bei ihm.
Ja doch, dann könnten wir das doch mit GRPC machen.
Und was ist mit CraftQL, was sagt da die Cloud Native Computing Foundation dazu?
Was sagen die zu CraftQL?
Kann man da irgendwie suchen zu?
Nix.
Ach gut, das ist kein Projekt von denen.
Dann verstehe ich.
CraftQL ist ja auch keine Implementierung.
Wobei, warum ist dann GRPC da?
Geh oben auf Landscape.
Projects.
Wo?
Lands? Ahja, Cloud.
Cloud Native MonkaS.
Mann, das ist eine geile Seite, die muss ich mir speichern.
GRPC.
Okay, da kann man da drinnen suchen.
Wie sucht man da drinnen?
Da hat wahrscheinlich bei den Cloud Native Leuten keiner dran gedacht, dass man auch die Seite durchsuchen möchte.
Kann man da suchen.
Cloud Mode.
Ich finde es nicht, wo ist es?
Hier, GRPC.
Alles klar.
Die sagen GRPC.
CraftQL.
Auf der Seite siehst du doch nichts.
Ah ne, es gibt nur eine CraftQL Engine.
Alles klar.
Was nicht alles gibt.
Oh ja, unsere Tabix Datenbank früher war auch riesengroß.
Die haben sie dann irgendwie partitioniert auf mehrere Kisten. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es genau gemacht haben.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit?
Oracle.
Aber ich bin bei einer Bank, wir haben das Geld, macht euch da keine Gedanken.
Die werden nicht pleite gehen.
Aber das Zeug ist der Teufel, Leute.
Wir haben ChatGPT letztens gefragt, was er für Clickbait Video Thumbnail Vorschläge hat.
Jetzt in Google Microsoft investieren.
Keine Ahnung, musst du dir selbst überlegen.
Ich bleibe weiter bei meinen ETF Stonks.
Was macht eigentlich mein Stonks gerade?
Nicht wirklich viel.
Nein, wir haben Aproxy.
Das ist wirklich gut, da kann man nichts gegen sagen.
Aha.
Der One Finger Man weiß Bescheid.
Hattet ihr mal einen blöden Chef?
Oh ja, hatte ich. Mehrfach. Mehrfach.
Die letzten zwei sind allerdings dafür gut gewesen.
Davor hatte ich eigentlich fast nur blöde Chefs.
Ich hatte beim Provider einen blöden Chef.
Hatte bei der Bank, wo ich jetzt arbeite, einen blöden Chef am Anfang.
Der nächste war auch blöde, der danach auch blöde.
Und die letzten zwei, die sind ganz gut gewesen.
Also der davor gewesen und der aktuelle ist immer noch.
Ich überlege gerade, die Abteilung zu wechseln, weil ich mit dem Chef nicht klarkomme.
Gestern beispielsweise wurde mir vorgeworfen, ich würde ihn und einen Kollegen
in einer Remont Arbeitsgruppe veräppeln und nicht wertschätzt.
Die haben immer Probleme, weil ich mit den anderen Kollegen vor Ort zum Mittagessen gegangen bin.
Mich knapp verabschieden.
Wo ist das Problem, wenn das Meeting fertig war?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Das ist eine doofe Situation, weil es ist ein Chef.
Also das ultimativen Ratschlag kann ich dir dann nicht geben.
Aber eins kann ich dir, für ihn war das Meeting nicht zu Ende.
Na ja gut, wenn ein Meeting nicht zu Ende ist, dann einfach rauszugehen in die Pause.
Ist tatsächlich nicht die feine englische Art.
Ich meine, ich kenne jetzt natürlich den genauen Ablauf nicht.
Aber normalerweise merkt man doch, wenn ein Meeting fertig ist.
Also meistens, wenn alle Tschüss sagen, ist ein Meeting fertig.
Und wenn das der Fall war, also wenn es für alle so aussah, als ist das Meeting fertig,
nur für ihn nicht, dann soll er an seiner Auffassungsgabe ein bisschen arbeiten.
Also es ist tatsächlich schwierig, wenn du persönliche Probleme mit deinem Chef hast.
Es gibt Leute, die kommen einfach miteinander nicht klar.
Da kann man noch so professionell sein.
Es gibt Leute, die reden immer aneinander vorbei und es gibt Leute,
die kommen von ihrer Art einfach nicht miteinander klar.
Und die können sich auch nur bis zum gewissen Punkt zusammenreißen.
Also das ist ja durchaus möglich.
Ansonsten ist das wahrscheinlich das einfachste, was du machen kannst, sachlich zu bleiben und sagen,
es haben sich alle verabschiedet, woher sollst du denn wissen?
Also was hätte er denn anders erwartet?
Weil wenn alle Tschüss sagen, dann scheint das Meeting wohl zu Ende zu sein.
Und außerdem, das einfachste, um solche Probleme zu vermeiden,
also wenn es ihn wirklich stört und das Probleme sind, die häufiger vorkommen,
das einfachste, um solche Probleme zu vermeiden, ist tatsächlich mal das zu machen,
wofür man als Chef da ist in dieser Situation.
Mit den Leuten reden und zwar, indem man sagt, okay, wir müssen halt so ein paar grundsätzliche Regeln aufstellen,
was Meetings angeht.
So nach dem Motto, solange noch Leute reden über das eingeladene Thema, ist das Meeting nicht vorbei.
Das Meeting ist erst vorbei, wenn, keine Ahnung, der Protokollschreiber alles aufgelegt hat.
Irgendwie sowas, wenn es da wirklich Probleme gibt.
Aber ansonsten, wenn es einfach ein Depp ist, ist es natürlich schwierig.
Es gibt unglaublich viele Vorgesetzte, die sich überhaupt nicht dafür eignen,
wo du das Gefühl hast, die sind da, weil sie sonst irgendwo untergekommen sind.
Also gibt es genug unfähige Leute.
Aber er muss halt einfach mal sagen, was er denn anders hätte erwartet.
Und beziehungsweise, wenn die Leute alle Tschüss sagen und gehen weg, ja.
Ja, die gibt's. Aber die Stunde wird bezahlt.
Das muss man sich dann immer vor Augen führen.
Also das ist eine Sache, wo ich festgestellt habe, also so, wie soll ich sagen, so auf gewollt,
so gewollt auf Alphatier machen, ist meistens nicht die richtige Variante,
um das Sache nicht eskalieren.
Also wenn man quasi dann sagt, ich lass mir hier gar nichts sagen und sonst was,
das führt meistens nicht dazu, dass die Situation entspannter wird auf Dauer.
Nee, bin ich nicht.
Es war kein wichtiges Meeting, es war eine Arbeitsgruppe in den Fortbildungstagen.
Gut, da weiß ich nicht, wie es da bei euch mit Anwesenheit aussieht.
Also wenn ich eine Schulung habe, da sollte man schon warten, bis dort Pause ist, bevor man abhaut.
Also man kann sich ja auch immer überlegen, das ist übrigens eine Sache, die ich an sich nicht verkehrt finde.
Man kann sich ja durchaus auch mal überlegen, okay, vielleicht ist das aus diesen und diesen Gründen verkehrt angekommen,
was ich gemacht habe. Also man kann natürlich auch mal ein bisschen gucken bei sich.
Vielleicht hätte man Sachen anders machen sollen, dass es nicht irgendwie zu Missverständnissen kommt
oder vielleicht hat man sich ja auch, wenn man wirklich drüber nachdenkt und auch mal sich in die Situation vom Chef reinversetzt.
Vielleicht war es auch wirklich keine gute Idee und man lässt es in Zukunft.
Ich kann es jetzt wirklich nicht sagen, weil ich nicht einschätzen kann, was da jetzt genau ist.
Also dafür labere ich relativ viel Privates mit den Leuten auf der Arbeit.
Ja, das ist immer Geschwätze, wir sind eine Familie, bla bla bla.
Gerade Gehaltserhöhungen abgelehnt bekommen, aber mitbekommen, dass alle neuen Leute auf demselben Entwicklungslevel,
da guck dich einfach mal um, was es sonst noch so gibt.
IT-Jobs, IT-Leute werden überall gesucht und dann wirst du sehen, wie schnell die sich rühren.
Sofern und diese Option besteht ja immer, gerade wenn man sich dann auch mal umguckt.
Die Option besteht ja immer, dass man vielleicht selbst, ich will nicht sagen, dass es bei dir so ist.
Ich sage nur, dass es eine Möglichkeit ist, dass man sich selbst als toller einschätzt, als man ist.
Das kommt ja manchmal vor.
Aber wenn du sagst, dass Leute auf ähnlichem Level wie dir, dann ist das natürlich fragwürdig.
Aber wie gesagt, guck dich um, guck dich um und du wirst sehen, wie schnell die hüpfen, wenn sie das mitbekommen,
wenn du wirklich gute Arbeit machst und du wirst auch dich vor Angeboten aktuell kaum retten können.
Das Gute ist, was wirklich eines der wenigen guten Sachen, was Corona uns gebracht hat, ist,
dass Homeoffice mittlerweile viel etablierter ist und dass auch viele Unternehmen deutschlandweit suchen
und auch sagen 100 Prozent Remod.
Sparst du oder investierst du? Ich kaufe ETFs. Nicht alles.
Das meiste liegt tatsächlich sinnlos rum.
Ja, mal abwarten.
In unserem Unternehmen gibt es so etwas wie Tage, wo man aus den Projekten rausgezogen wird
und die Tage für andere Themen investieren kann.
Da können Schulungen stattfinden oder lockere Arbeitsgruppen, wo man intern tuts.
Also wenn es eine lockere Arbeitsgruppe ist, wo quasi klar ist, jeder kommt und geht zur Mittagspause,
wenn es gerade passt, dann sehe ich da überhaupt kein Problem drin. Vielleicht weiß das der Chef plus nicht,
weil er noch nie sowas mitgemacht hat.
Dann würde ich ihn einfach fragen, was er denn erwartet, weil die Regeln sind dann relativ klar.
Oder warum er das anders einschätzt, kann man ihn ja mal fragen.
Es scheint ja endlich, dass man sich da ein bisschen auf den Weg bringt,
wenn man etwas einschätzt, kann man ihn ja mal fragen.
Es scheint ja etabliertes Vorgehen zu sein, dass die Leute in diesen lockeren Arbeitsgruppen
Mittagsessen gehen, wenn es gerade passt.
Also warum er in der anderen Ansicht ist, wie er darauf kommt, kann man ihn ja durchaus mal fragen.
Selbst der Chef war stundenlang, dann wäre er erst recht, dann würde ich ihn erst recht mal fragen,
was denn jetzt eigentlich genau, also wie er sich das denn vorgestellt hat, auf welcher Grundlage,
also wie er darauf kommt.
Mein Unternehmen bildet absolut miserabel aus, hast du einen Tipp, wie man damit umgehen sollte?
Ja, selbst was lernen, scheiß drauf, was die machen.
Du wirst sie nicht verbessern können, du kannst natürlich, kenn den Laden nicht,
du kannst natürlich sagen, hier guck mal, ich würde mir wünschen, dass ich mal einer hinsetze,
du kannst durchaus, selbst wenn ihr mal einen Ausbildungsvertreter bei euch habt und sowas,
der dein Hauptansprechpartner für sowas ist, kannst du natürlich mal sagen,
dass du dir mehr in diese Richtung wünschen würdest, aber ganz ehrlich, so wie du das sagst,
sieht es für mich eher so aus, als sind die nicht in der Lage, dich ordentlich auszubilden.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal daran, weil sie es nicht wissen,
sie können es wahrscheinlich einfach nicht besser.
Das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist scheiß drauf, du wirst sie wahrscheinlich nicht ändern können,
das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist selbst lernen, was dich interessiert,
und selbst besser werden in deinen bevorzugten Gebieten,
sodass du später viel Knowhow in den Bereichen hast und dementsprechend auch deutlich bessere Chancen hast,
in den Bereichen arbeiten zu können, auf die du Bock hast.
Das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist selbst lernen, was übrigens in der IT eigentlich immer so ist.
Man kann sich nie darauf verlassen, dass man alles, dass man die Sachen irgendwie großartig beigebracht bekommt.
Wir haben auch so ein paar Kandidaten bei uns, das verstehe ich auch immer nicht,
wenn es was Neues gibt, sagen die pauschal, ach, schreibt mal in den Chat, ob ihr auch so Leute kennt, ja?
Schreibt mir das mal in den Chat, das würde mich echt interessieren, aber wir haben mal uns so Leuten, es gibt was Neues,
und das Erste, was du von den Leuten hörst, ach, das ist ja schon wieder was Neues,
davon habe ich erstmal keine Ahnung, die sollen mir erstmal eine Schulung bezahlen, dann arbeite ich auch damit.
Kennt ihr so Leute? Das triggert mich immer richtig, wo ich mir denke so,
meine Güte, es geht hier doch jetzt nicht irgendwie, wir bauen doch jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Rakete,
die irgendwie zum Mond fliegen muss oder so, das sind halt neue Tools oder neue Services,
die muss man sich halt mal angucken und wenn man die sich angeguckt hat, ein paar Tage verwenden,
da kommt man da schon rein, jetzt stellt euch mal nicht so an, Alter.
Was macht dich happy? Prime Subs.
Ich meine, muss man ehrlich sein.
Noch nie gehabt, also wir haben viele Leute bei uns, wir haben wirklich viele Leute,
wir haben viel zu viele Leute in der Richtung bei uns.
Es gibt eine Sache, die ihr machen könnt, also natürlich mit eurem Chef reden, das ist klar,
aber wenn sich da nichts tut, wirklich, vorwärts geht es eigentlich nur, wenn ihr euch mal umguckt,
das heißt ja nicht, dass ihr direkt kündigen müsst.
Ihr müsst euch umgucken, weil was Leute euch erzählen, seriously,
wenn ihr mit irgendwelchen Kollegen zusammensitzt und die sagen, du kriegst aber viel zu wenig Geld,
da kannst du erstmal nicht allzu viel drauf geben.
Das Einzige ist, wenn die wirklich mal auch so Butter bei die Fische machen und wirklich auch erzählen,
was sie verdienen und du in einer ähnlichen Position seid, ansonsten bringt dir das wenigstens.
Das Einzige, was wirklich hilft, ist erstmal selbst gucken, sich mal umhören,
sich vielleicht auch mal woanders bewerben, vielleicht auch mal woanders mal die ein oder anderen Gespräche führen,
gucken, was dort für Gehaltsbereiche möglich sind, weil dann weißt du schon mal, was du dafür bezahlt bekommen würdest
und vielleicht ist auch jemand dabei, wo du sagen wirst, ah, da würde ich gerne hin,
weil ich habe Schiss vor dem aktuellen Jobmarkt, wo die Unternehmen jetzt Leute...
Leute, ihr müsst keinen Schiss, wenn es jemanden gibt auf dieser Welt,
der keine Angst davor haben muss, entlassen zu werden.
Da sind es Leute, die was können und in der IT arbeiten.
Ihr solltet das Gegenteil von Schiss haben.
Ihr solltet sagen, mir gefällt was nicht, mach besser oder ich hau ab, um es jetzt mal übertrieben zu sein.
Ihr müsst euch wirklich keine Gedanken machen, die rennen euch die Bude ein.
Und wenn ihr es nicht glaubt, wenn ihr es nicht glaubt, auch wenn das nicht die besten Angebote sind,
aber wenn ihr es nicht glaubt, macht euch einen Link in den Account
und schreibt einfach mal die Sachen rein, so an Skills und ein bisschen im Business Speak.
Ihr bekommt, ihr bekommt, was weiß ich, 10 Anfragen am Tag, wenn es mal reicht, je nachdem was es ist.
Das ist natürlich nicht unbedingt gut, alles, was da an Anfragen kommt.
Das meiste ist Schrott, aber nur, dass ihr seht, ihr kriegt massig, massig Anfragen.
Und selbst, wenn ihr euch irgendwo bewerbt, die sind sehr, also zumindest, was ich jetzt mitbekomme,
ich hab mich jetzt ja auch mitbekommen, die sind da mittlerweile echt sehr flexibel und entgegengezogen.
Zum Beispiel, wir nehmen mal den Job, auf den ich mich jetzt beworben habe, wo es jetzt auch geklappt hat.
Und wo ich jetzt, also bei der Versicherung in Frankfurt, da wo ich jetzt auch am ersten Birtenanfang werde.
Das ist, die sind nicht unbekannt.
Also das ist schon ein Unternehmen, was die Leute kennen.
Ja, ich sag euch den Namen nicht, aber das kennt man.
Und selbst dort hat sich oder haben sich nur ganz wenige auf diese Stelle beworben.
Also ich, ich kann es euch jetzt, ich weiß es ja auch nur vom Erzählen, also im Prinzip keine Ahnung, wie viel, wie viel es jetzt wirklich waren.
Aber ich wüsste schon, wie viele es jetzt wirklich waren.
Aber ich wüsste nicht, warum die Mist erzählen sollen.
Ich weiß, dass sich auf meine Stelle genau einer beworben hat, außer mir.
Einer.
Und das war intern.
Und dort ist es dann irgendwie nicht, nicht zustande gekommen, weil er irgendwie doch keinen Bock mehr hatte oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Es hat sich einer beworben und das war eigentlich jemand, der den Vorzug hätte, bevor ich diese Stelle überhaupt hätte bekommen können.
Einer.
Und das ist, das ist eine bekannte, das ist eine bekannte Versicherung, das ist ein großes, großes Frankfurter Unternehmen.
Die Stellenanzeige war jetzt, jetzt nichts herausragendes, aber jetzt auch nicht super schlecht.
Und sie bezahlen wirklich gut.
Und das hat sich einer und das war intern irgendwie beworben.
Also ihr müsst euch wirklich keine Gedanken machen, ihr müsst, ihr müsst das Gegenteil von Schiss haben, den Job zu verlieren.
Ihr könnt davon ausgehen, niemand, der noch bei Sinnen ist und der nicht Google oder Microsoft ist
und schlicht und ergreifend einfach viel zu viele Leute in den letzten Jahren über eingestellt hat und festgestellt hat,
ups, wollen wir gar nicht, schmeißt aktuell IT Leute freiwillig raus.
Und wenn sie es machen, kann ja durchaus sein, irgendwelche Umstrukturierungsmaßnahmen findet ihr wahrscheinlich um die nächste Ecke was besseres.
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich würde erstmal nicht so viel drauf geben, was dir jemand erzählt, so nach dem Motto, du bist unterbezahlt, sonst wie, da wird viel Mist erzählt.
Das Einzige, wie du das feststellen kannst, ist wirklich mal dich ein bisschen umhören.
Du kannst dir Stellen raussuchen bei dir in der, in der, in der Nähe.
Du kannst dir wirklich die besten, die besten Sachen raussuchen, was dich am, am größten anspricht.
Ja, du musst dir nicht irgendeinen Mist nehmen, such dir wirklich ein paar gute Sachen raus, wo du sagen würdest,
hey, das gefällt mir, da hätte ich Bock drauf, vielleicht gefällt es dir auch wirklich so gut, dass du dann am Ende hingehst.
Du kannst entweder dort anrufen, wenn du Fragen hast, du kannst natürlich dich auch gleich bewerben
und einfach mal checken, was so abgeht. Ich meine, es zwingt dich ja keiner den Kram anzunehmen.
Und dann sagst du im Zweifelsfall, hier Chef, ich hab mich, ich hab einen anderen Vertrag auf dem Tisch liegen,
wenn du das vorher nicht öffentlich machen willst, ist ja sinnvoll, gibt ja durchaus Unternehmen, da
kriegst du vielleicht Probleme, wenn du das im Vorfeld erzählst.
Also ich hab es meinem Chef, meinem Chef beispielsweise schon seit ein paar Monaten vorher erzählt,
dass ich mich am Bewerben bin und auch vielversprechende Sachen habe
und jetzt auch einen Vertrag auf dem Tisch liegen habe, dann ein bisschen später.
Aber gut, muss sich jeder, jeder überlegen, wie er das macht.
Ich würde es nicht empfehlen, das vorher zu erzählen.
Ich würde eher die Klappe halten.
Du kannst vielleicht, wenn du wirklich gute Kollegen hast und dich mit denen ein bisschen abstimmen willst,
so hier, hast du mal gehört, wie findest du meine Werbung, kann man machen, wenn du denkst,
die halten die Klappe. Das ist kein Ding.
Aber großartig, aber großartig, an die große Glocke hängen würde ich es nicht.
Und wenn du dann was hast, kannst du sagen, hier Jungs, ich habe ein anderes Angebot vorliegen.
Was geht denn bei euch noch?
Und dann werden die wahrscheinlich denken, wir haben doch kein Geld, das letzte Jahr war so schlecht,
die Geschäfte liefen schlecht, Corona war schlecht und jetzt die Inflation.
Wie kannst du so gemein zu uns sein und jetzt sagen, du willst mehr Geld
und wenn du nicht mehr Geld bekommst, dann gehst du auch noch.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass sie dann ein bisschen Panik schieben und so tun, als bist du da ganz böse.
Aber unterm Strich, sie werden dir entweder ein besseres Angebot machen und wenn du es da ganz gut findest, nimmst du es an.
Ansonsten gehst du mal anders hin.
Ich verstehe, dass das Überwindung kostet.
Ich kann euch das wirklich aus eigener Erfahrung sagen.
Ich bin faul as fuck.
Ihr kennt mich mit der Zeit, Leute.
Ich bin der faulste Mensch, den es so gibt auf der Welt.
Und es war für mich wirklich eine Überwindung.
Es war eine Überwindung, mich woanders zu bewerben oder mich überhaupt mit dem Thema auseinanderzusetzen
oder mich überhaupt um das Thema zu kümmern.
Not wrong, Lulve.
Ja, guck mal, wie lange sag ich schon, dass ich meine Dot-Files hochlade?
Wie lange will ich meine Dot-Files schon hochladen?
Drei Wochen und ich hab's nicht gemacht.
Und ich bin faul as fuck und ich hab da wirklich keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Ich hab mir auf der Arbeit genervt, was Geld angeht, was Homeoffice angeht.
Und es hat sich einfach nix getan.
Und irgendwann war es halt so groß und der Abfuck auch so groß, dass ich gesagt hab, ich guck mich jetzt um.
Dazu beigetragen hat noch mein Kollege, mit dem ich außerhalb von der Firma eigentlich mich auch so ganz gut verstehe,
weil ich von ihm wusste, der will auch weg, der bewirbt sich auch woanders.
Das war für mich der Anschluss zu sagen, weißt du was, Max, wenn der abhaut,
da hast du eigentlich wirklich keinen Bock mehr da zu bleiben.
Da hab ich dann angefangen und ich weiß, das kostet Überwindung.
Aber es ist nicht irgendwie super aufwendig oder so.
Also ihr müsst den Lebenslauf schreiben.
Das ist ein bisschen nervig, da müsst ihr euch ein bisschen mit Sätze, Texts, Bearbeitungen deiner Art einsetzen.
Da müsst ihr ein bisschen Vorlagen basteln und ladet euch was im Internet drunter.
Oder ihr könnt auch das mit Latech machen und das irgendwie schön setzen oder in Photoshop, wo ihr Bock drauf habt.
Ihr müsst eine Bewerbung, ihr müsst einen Lebenslauf schreiben, den möglichst ansprechenden,
das braucht mal einen Nachmittag Arbeit und ein paar Tage Feintuning,
mehrere Tage verteilt mit ein bisschen Feedback von neuen.
Ihr müsst einen Lebenslauf schreiben, aber Lebenslauf schreiben ist tatsächlich das Anstrengendste an der ganzen Geschichte.
Und ihr könnt euch ja dafür auch eine Vorlage kaufen oder runterladen.
Das ist der Rest, ohne Mist. Ich kann es nur aus dem berichten, was ich jetzt gemacht habe.
Die Bewerbungsprozesse sind mittlerweile wirklich easy as fuck.
Also ihr könnt euch bei nahezu allem online bewerben.
Also da ist nichts mehr mit. Ich muss mir irgendwie einen Anschreiben aus den Fingern saugen und dann per Post verschicken.
Das geht mittlerweile alles online. Wenn es nicht online geht, würde ich die Frage stellen, ob ich zu dem Laden überhaupt hin will.
Das geht mittlerweile alles online. Ihr ladet dort euren Lebenslauf hoch.
Ihr ladet vielleicht noch eine Skill-Liste. Ich persönlich habe da jetzt gute Erfahrungen gemacht mit so einer Skill-Liste, was man alles kann.
Weil vieles passt halt nicht in den Lebenslauf. Du kannst in den Lebenslauf reinschreiben, welche Sachen man gemacht hat von wann bis wann.
Aber so wirklich eine Auflistung an Skills finde ich auch zur Einschätzung für die ganz gut.
Und dass sie auch noch sehen, das passt zu der Stelle. Skill-Liste, Lebenslauf.
Gut, und dann, je nachdem, ob ihr da jemand kennt oder ob ihr euch da so bleibt, so ein bisschen anschreiben vielleicht noch.
Aber das ist gar kein großer Akt. Das ist überhaupt kein großer Akt, sich zu bewerben.
Und ein weiterer Vorteil ist, nicht nur, dass ihr rausbekommt, was denn so aktuell so der Wert ist, den IT-Experten haben in eurem Bereich.
Nee, ihr habt noch einen weiteren Vorteil. Ihr lernt mal wieder ein bisschen Vorstellungsgespräche führen.
Dass es so plötzlich anhört, das ist schon ein bisschen Übungssache.
Also ich meine, ich habe jetzt drei Stück gehabt, bis ich den neuen Vertrag unterschrieben habe.
Das erste hat nicht hingehauen, weil erst ich Corona hatte, dann mein Ansprechpartner dort Corona hat.
Und am Ende haben sie gemeint, ah sie wollen dieses Jahr doch niemand haben, okay.
Bei den anderen habe ich einen Vertrag in der Post gehabt und jetzt habe ich bei den anderen, bei den noch anderen habe ich unterschrieben.
Was auch gut ist, GitHub, GitHub-Profil und sowas, wenn man Projekte hat.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so schlimm, als wären Vorstellungsgespräche so schwer, weil ihr müsst euch jetzt überlegen, ihr seid in der besten Situation.
Ihr habt einen festen Job, vielleicht nicht einen, den ihr wahnsinnig super geil findet und für immer machen wollt, aber ihr habt einen festen Job.
Das heißt, ihr könnt euch bedenkenlos bewerben und wenn es nicht klappt, ist egal.
Da könnt ihr sagen, okay hat nicht gepasst, hat mir nicht gefallen, denen hat es nicht gefallen.
Und ihr könnt es als Erfahrung verbuchen, die euch in Zukunft was bringt.
Weil wenn ihr dann mal lernt, was ihr quasi wert seid, vielleicht auch ein bisschen Erfahrung habt, was Vorstellungsgespräche und sowas angeht.
Da könnt ihr vielleicht auch nochmal eine Runde mit eurem Chef reden und es klappt dann besser.
Aber wie gesagt, ich würde es gar nicht öffentlich machen, dass ich mich bewerbe woanders, bis ich was Handfestes in der Tasche habe bzw. halt was zum unterschreiben habe.
Also was ich hingeschickt habe, ich mach demnächst noch ein Video, wo ich meine Lebenslaufskillliste und sowas schreibe.
Was ich hingeschickt habe ist folgendes. Moment.
Ich kann es euch jetzt nicht zeigen, aber ich werde mal ein bisschen vorlesen.
Also was ich hingeschrieben habe ist berufliche Erfahrung habe ich hingeschrieben.
Also 2013 bis heute, 2011 bis 2012, 2010 bis 2011, dann habe ich hingeschrieben Ausbildung.
Das habe ich unten drunter geschrieben. Ich habe tatsächlich mit dem aktuellsten zuerst angefangen.
Dann habe ich hingeschrieben, dass ich seit 2012 nebenberuflicher Webvideoproduzent bin. Zum ersten Mal, dass ich das erwähnt habe.
Dann habe ich hingeschrieben, ich habe mehrere Obersourceprojekte auf GitHub und habe mein GitHub mit verlinkt.
Bei den einzelnen beruflichen Erfahrungen habe ich bei den Stationen zwischendurch noch hingeschrieben, was ich da so gemacht habe.
Zum Beispiel habe ich dann hingeschrieben, 2013 bis bla bla bla, meine Aufgaben waren umsetzen und Etablierung eines Infrastructure as Code Release Managements
für 3000 plus Linux Systeme mit Hilfe von Git, Puppet, Ansible, Terraform und Formen.
Linux System Engineering, Red Hat, Ubuntu, Hochverfügbarkeit, Auswahlsicherheit, Security, Kontainerisierung und Skalierung, Tool Entwicklung, C-Sharp,.NET, Go, Javascript,
Konzeptionierung, Einführung, neue technische Dokumentation, Linungssysteme, inklusive automatischem Datenimport.
Und weil noch ein bisschen Platz war, habe ich hingeschrieben, Migration von Jenkins auf GitHub Actions.
Was ich eigentlich zwar gemacht habe, aber jetzt kein Hauptbestandteil ist, aber irgendwie war da noch ein bisschen Platz.
So was habe ich da hingeschrieben zum Beispiel. Ich mache da noch demnächst ein Video drüber, wo wir uns das mal zusammen angucken.
So, so viel dazu. Eine World ETF, sonst nichts.
Dann ist dein Teamleiter kacke. Dann konnte das nicht richtig verkaufen.
Also dass man vielleicht nicht bei allem 100% immer zustimmt, aber wenn dein Teamleiter mit was ankommt, sollte sich auf jeden Fall schon was tun.
Es sei denn, und das darf, das kann natürlich auch sein, dass das Taktik ist. Man sollte da wirklich manchmal mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass das Taktik ist. So nach dem Motto, dass dein Teamleiter unter Bereichsleiter unter einer Decke stecken und die sich ausgemacht haben,
ok, es gibt nicht mehr Geld und damit du bei deinen Leuten nicht schlecht dastehst, sagen wir denen einfach, ich hätte es abgelehnt.
Das kann durchaus auch sein. Oder dein Teamleiter sagt einfach und kann sich richtig verkaufen.
Das meiste, wie die gucken werden, wenn du sagst, ich habe einen anderen Vertrag auf dem Tisch liegen, da werden sie dann wieder rumjammern.
So nach dem Motto, oh es war so schlecht und Corona und die Geschäftszahlen und jetzt willst du auch noch gehen, oh mein Gott.
Aber da hätten sie sich anderweitig überlegen müssen. Oder sie können einfach mehr Geld auf den Tisch legen.
Die Leute sind ja letztendlich bestechbar. Bestechlich.
Alle Leute, die in die Arbeit gehen, machen das, zumindest zu einem nicht unerheblichen Teil, ich will nicht sagen, nur aber nicht zu einem unerheblichen Teil,
weil sie Geld verdienen, weil sie keinen Bock haben, unter der Brücke schlafen zu müssen.
Das ist eigentlich die beste Antwort, die man geben könnte, so nach dem Motto, ja, Herr Max, was hat sie dazu gebracht, sich bei uns zu bewerben?
Ja, ich möchte essen und nicht unter der Brücke schlafen müssen.
Natürlich kannst du das nicht sagen, natürlich musst du dir irgendwie den Scheiß aus den Fingern saugen.
Du könntest auch eine ehrliche Antwort geben, ich will Geld verdienen.
Und es gibt ja sicherlich oftmals auch noch andere Gründe.
Aber für viele ist es bestimmt auch der Hauptgrund, sie wollen schlecht und ergreifend Geld verdienen.
Hey, was ist das für eine bescheuere Aussage?
DarkSide schreibt, er hatte einige Bewerbungsgespräche, eigentlich wollte ich auch ein paar YouTube-Videos kommen, aber wir haben noch eine Stunde Zeit.
Er hatte einige Bewerbungsgespräche jetzt und ich habe das Gefühl, man durchhäuft wieder meine mindestens zwei bis vier Gespräche.
Früher hat man das...
Also, gut, wie gesagt, meine Erfahrung hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich habe mich jetzt dreimal beworben, einmal hatte ich nur ein Gespräch.
Dort, wo ich einen Vertrag auf dem Tisch liegen hatte, hatte ich zwei Gespräche.
Das erste Gespräch war mit einer von der Personalabteilung, mit dem, ja, keine Ahnung, Bereichsabteilungsleiter und meinem zukünftigen Teamleiter.
Remote ging das Ganze über Teams und dann hatte ich noch ein zweites Gespräch mit denen vor Ort und danach habe ich einen Vertrag gekriegt.
Mit dort, wo ich jetzt unterschrieben habe, ging das tatsächlich sehr schnell.
Da habe ich genau ein Gespräch, okay, ich habe vorher ganz kurz telefoniert mit ihm und dann habe ich vor Ort ein Gespräch und dann habe ich einen Vertrag gekriegt.
Das ging mega schnell.
Was das Thema heute ist, das Thema heute ist, dass es kein Thema gibt.
Ich widme mich euren Problemen, beziehungsweise wir gucken uns gleich noch eine Stunde lang irgendwie ein paar YouTube-Videos an und dann gehe ich ins Bett.
Ich habe jetzt so lange nicht gestreamt, ich musste jetzt einfach mal wieder online kommen.
Und ich hatte heute Abend auch wirklich Bock darauf mal wieder streamen einzuschalten.
Ich habe mir gedacht, warum, warum sollte ich MMO Kreisel-Crime machen, wenn ich auch Prime-Subs abgreifen kann?
Aber schon.
Knojector, Dankeschön für den Prime-Subs und ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich das betonen soll.
Hymk, Hj, Imk, Dankeschön für den Prime-Subs, wie auch immer, weil das so genau ausspricht.
Hatnock, Pogger-Subskription, 8 Monate, jetzt bin ich happy, jetzt gab es so viele Prime-Subs und du hast den Diamant-Keks unlocked.
Ja, kannst du machen.
Also Arbeitzeugnis anfordern ist prinzipiell keine schlechte Idee.
Die haben bei mir nicht sehr viel Wert drauf gelegt, aber es war doch ganz gut, als ich es hatte.
Also wie gesagt, da habe ich mich ja lange genug jetzt drüber außer du musst kein Schiss haben.
Gerade wenn du in der IT tätig bist und ein bisschen Plan hast.
Ja, so sieht es aus, wir müssen das Gegenteil von Schiss haben, wir müssen Anti-Schiss haben.
Als Rollout-Manager, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ein Rollout-Manager sein soll.
Ich meine, ich kann mir natürlich was drunter zusammenreimen.
Du kümmerst dich wahrscheinlich um Updates oder sowas.
Package-Updates, neue Software-Releases, Patch-Management, keine Ahnung, was das sein muss.
Also das müssen die ja schon reinschreiben, was die denn unter einem Rollout-Manager verstehen, ansonsten kann das ja alles bedeuten.
Es ist eh Schall und Rauch, wie die ganzen Jobs heißen.
Da denkt sich eh jeder was anderes aus.
Würdest du einem Berufseinsteiger eine 100% Remount-Stelle empfehlen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Puh, das ist eine gute Frage, also...
Also ich bin mir nicht 100% nicht sicher, aber...
Wenn es eine Stelle ist, die du nur annehmen kannst, weil sie eben Remount ist, dann warum nicht?
Also zum Beispiel du wohnst jetzt in München und nimmst eine Stelle in Berlin an oder wohnst in Frankfurt und nimmst eine Stelle in Berlin an.
Warum nicht? Ich meine, da kannst du ja vor Ort gar nicht hin.
Und dann finde ich es auch nicht verwerflich zu sagen...
Oder was heißt verwerflich, wer weiß ich das falsch machen.
Da finde ich das auch nicht irgendwie blöd zu sagen, ich mache das nicht, nur weil es 100% Remount ist.
Da spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen.
Ich denke eh, dass in Zukunft noch mehr Unternehmen auch anfangen werden 100% Remount-Stellen rauszuhauen.
Es gibt jetzt schon viele, auch durch Corona, vor Corona war es ja noch gar nicht.
Solche sind jetzt wieder ein bisschen am Zurückrudern, aber gerade wie der IT-Jobmarkt aussieht, die werden sich das nicht leisten können, das durchzuhalten.
Ja, warum nicht?
Insgesamt würde ich sagen, es ist nicht verkehrt, wenn man ein bisschen Enterprise-Businessluft vor Ort schon mitbekommen hat.
Auch für die Zukunft.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das unbedingt notwendig ist, also wenn du eine gute erste Stelle 100% Remount hast, die in der anderen Stadt ist, die nur Remount geht, machs.
Sprich dir überhaupt nichts dagegen, wird dir niemand irgendwie negativ auslegen oder so.
Aber ich glaube auf lange Sicht zumindest, weil ein bisschen so die Business-Enterprise-Luft, wie das so ist, weil mitbekommen zu haben, ist glaube ich gar nicht so verkehrt.
Es muss ja kein 100% Vor-Ort-Job sein, das würde ich heutzutage auch nicht mehr machen.
Aber was mit einmal die Woche alle 14 Tage ins Büro oder sowas ist nicht verkehrt, wenn das die Lage der Stelle zulässt, dass man ein bisschen was mal mitbekommen hat.
Wenn man danach für sich entscheidet, hey, ich hab da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf und ich will überhaupt gar nichts mit Leuten da vor Ort zu tun haben,
dann kann man sich ja nach wie vor immer auf 100% Remount Sachen bewerben.
Aber ab und zu mal so ein bisschen so die Enterprise-Business-Welt vor Ort mitbekommen zu haben, ist glaube ich gar nicht so verkehrt.
Benutzt gesehen überhaupt noch jemand?
Ja, siehste?
Braucht man ein Triggerwort, dass die Anfragen kommen?
Ja, du solltest Chief Cloud, Senior Chief Cloud Solution Native Blockchain Engineer sein.
Dann klappt das.
Du kannst da reinschreiben, was der Realität entspricht.
Architekt natürlich, nicht Engineer, Architekt klar, Expert-Architekt.
Stimmt, die Anfragen willst du nicht haben, das ist auch wieder rüber.
Ich würde einfach die Skills reinschreiben, die der Realität entsprechen, weil du willst ja auch Sachen machen, auf die du Bock hast.
Man kann es natürlich schon schön verkaufen, so ist das nicht.
Was ich zum Beispiel gut fand, dass ich gesagt habe, ich habe 15 Jahre Erfahrung in der Frankfurter Finanzbranche, was ja so ist.
Normalerweise ohne euch Leute, wäre ich gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen, das reinzuschreiben.
Das hat sich hier im Chat so ergeben, dass ich auf die Idee gekommen bin, ich könnte das reinschreiben, weil das ist ja kein Skill im eigentlichen Sinne.
Ich meine, es ist kein Skill, 15 Jahre in irgendeinem Bereich gewesen zu sein, aber ich habe es trotzdem reingeschrieben und das kam gut an.
Ich meine, im Nachhinein verständlich, weil ich habe 15 Jahre Erfahrung in der Frankfurter Finanzbranche und ich bin weiterhin tätig in der Frankfurter Finanzbranche.
Also kann ich irgendwo schon verstehen, dass ich das ganz gut fand.
Du hast ab dem 1.3. einen neuen Job, in der Softwareentwicklung hat jemand etwas nervös.
Das ist nicht schlimm, ein bisschen nervös zu sein, das ist mein Tipp.
Das macht überhaupt nichts, ein bisschen nervös sein ist besser, als der gechillteste Typ und dann auch irgendwie blöde Sprüche machen.
Ein bisschen nervös schadet nicht.
Das ist normal, dass man ein bisschen nervös ist, wenn man neue Sachen macht.
Ich meine, wenn du jetzt nicht wie dieser Schwitz-Meme-Typ, dieses Schwitzer-Meme-Kerl aussiehst, dem das schon komplett so wasserfallmäßig runterläuft, ist alles okay.
Ja, ist tatsächlich so.
Und das ist auch so.
Das ist auch so.
Müssen sie ja auch.
Guck mal, realistisch betrachtet hat doch ein Unternehmen drei Varianten, um Leute zu bekommen.
Das erste ist und die einfachste Variante ist, nichts machen und die Leute mit Geld zu kacken.
Dann bekommst du auch Leute, musst nur genug bezahlen.
Also einfach Fett, Kohle reinbuttern ist das erste.
Das zweite ist, sich irgendwie attraktiver machen.
Ja, es kann ja durchaus sein, dass das Unternehmen schon attraktiv ist, aber die Stellenanzeigen bloß beschissen sind.
Das kommt bestimmt öfters vor, als man denkt.
Also dass sie das einfach attraktiver gestalten.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, es gibt drei Sachen, was Unternehmen machen können.
Ich kann nicht Chat lesen und dabei reden, das krieg ich einfach nicht gebacken.
Ich hab jetzt wieder die Hälfte vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Fällt mir bestimmt gleich wieder ein.
Achso, ja ich weiß wieder.
Es gibt drei Varianten, was Unternehmen machen können, um Leute zu bekommen.
Sie können mehr Geld bezahlen, sie können sich attraktiver machen oder sie können einfach radikal ihre Ansprüche runterschrauben.
So nach dem Motto, hey wir haben hier einen komplizierten Job, den lassen wir jetzt einfach jedem machen.
Und am Ende wird es wahrscheinlich eine Kombination aus allen drei sein.
Die werden mehr bezahlen müssen, die werden sich attraktiver machen müssen und die werden ihre Ansprüche runterschrauben müssen, wenn sie IT Leute haben wollen.
Weil wenn sie das nicht machen, dann atmen die anderen zwei Punkte halt aus.
Also ich sehe es bei mir dort, wo ich gerade arbeite,
bei uns versuchen sie die Stellanzeigen attraktiver zu gestalten.
Sie bezahlen nicht mehr Geld, was auch dazu beiträgt, dass sie keine Leute finden und sie haben ihre Ansprüche drastisch runtergeschraubt.
Was man daran sieht, das ist jetzt wirklich kein Witz, der arme kann da nichts für.
Die haben ihm das so erzählt, dass eine Stelle, wo früher Linux-Administrationen-Administratoren gesucht wurden,
was auch sinnvoll ist, wenn man nämlich eine komplette Umgebung hat mit tausenden von Linux-Systemen,
dass dort mittlerweile Leute eingestellt werden, die keine Ahnung von Linux haben.
Und die das auch nicht in der Bewerbung stehen haben und das auch im Vorstellungsgespräch sagen, dass sie keine Ahnung von Linux haben,
sondern sich nur mit Windows auskennen oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen.
Also sie haben ihre Ansprüche so weit runtergeschraubt, dass sie für eine Stelle, die eigentlich Linux-Know-How voraussetzt,
Leute einstellen ohne Linux-Erfahrung.
Das muss nicht zwangsläufig schlimm sein, solange du Leute einstellst, die fähig sind und bereit sind, sich neue Sachen anzugucken.
Aber da sieht man schon, die müssen auch ihren Anspruch runterschrauben.
Bei euch müssen 6.500 Leute gehen. Krass. Aber wahrscheinlich nicht alles in der IT.
Und selbst wenn es alles in der IT wäre, das wäre ja nur ein Tropfen auf einem heißen Stein versus die offenen, unbesetzten Stellen.
Aber das fähige Leute sind in die Ratsfahrt zu unter.
Du fängst am 11.4. du bekommst 40-45% mehr.
Da seht ihr mal Leute, was da alles drin ist.
Das ist ein Gehaltssprung, den werdet ihr so, also ich gehe mal davon aus, gleiche Arbeitszeit wie vorher,
den werdet ihr so beim gleichen Arbeitgeber auf gar keinen Fall haben.
Gut, ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr, weil dafür ist es bei mir schon in der Summe zu viel.
Ich meine, ich hätte da nichts dagegen, aber die werden mir nicht einfach 150k bezahlen oder sowas.
Man kann es ja irgendwie übertreiben.
Wobei, ich meine, nehmen würde ich es natürlich.
Da sieht man, da ist einiges drin.
Wupplos ist faul, das ist richtig.
Nee, ich würde nicht die erst beste Lebenslaufvorlage nehmen.
Ich würde mir schon eine aus dem Internet holen, die ein bisschen zu euch passt.
Und jetzt auch vielleicht nicht das erste Google-Ergebnis.
Also ich habe auch eine Wortvorlage, die habe ich nicht aus dem Internet.
Die habe ich von einem Arbeitskollege, der sich beworben hat und die fand ich ganz hübsch und habe ihn gefragt, ob ich die nehmen kann.
Also auch was da angeht, ultra faul.
Es werden überall händeringt Leute gesucht, was IT angeht.
Und das stimmt schon, du hast recht.
Nicht nur IT, aber von anderen Bereichen habe ich halt keine Ahnung.
Ich finde gerade, Battlefield muss auch in die Skillliste, nicht nur aus Battlefield.
Auch die Warzone wins, alles.
Zeigt immerhin, was du für ein guter Teamplayer online bist.
Open Source Referenzen sind auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Also ich habe mein GitHub Profil mit verlinkt.
Und halt eine Skillliste hingeschickt.
Wir schauen uns das alles zusammen in dem Video an.
Was sollte man machen, wenn in der Firma wirklich alles perfekt ist,
jedoch das Gehalt ist jetzt nicht schlecht mit einem neuen Job um 20 bis 30 Prozent gesteigert werden könnte?
Du musst dich erstmal fragen, ob du irgendwelche Sachen aktuell nicht machen kannst aufgrund des Gehaltes.
Also wenn du dein Leben so leben kannst, wie du willst,
wenn du da keine großen Einschränkungen machen willst,
wenn du nicht irgendwelche Sachen vorhast, wo du sagst, dafür brauche ich 20 bis 30 Prozent mehr,
und ansonsten alles perfekt ist, bleib halt da.
Was jetzt nicht heißt, dass du nicht dort versuchen kannst, ein bisschen mehr Geld rauszuholen.
Welches Video ist gemeint? Kommt noch.
Dass ich noch ein Video mache mit meinem Lebenslauf und Skillliste für meine Bewerbung,
dass ihr euch das mal angucken könnt.
Natürlich muss ich ja ein paar Sachen schwärzen, zum Beispiel das Foto muss ich raus machen.
Also so würde ich es handhaben, ich würde mich fragen,
also will ich irgendwas machen, wo mir die Kohle nicht für reicht?
Gibt es irgendwelche Einschränkungen, die ich jetzt habe, die ich da nicht machen muss?
Ansonsten, wenn du top zufrieden bist und dein Gehalt okay ist und du jetzt nichts hast,
wo du sagst, ich brauche die 20 bis 30 Prozent Geld unbedingt mehr,
dann würde ich einfach da bleiben.
Geld ist mit Sicherheit der wichtigste Faktor, was Jobs angeht für viele, aber nicht der einzige.
Du musst ja halt überlegen, ob das das aufwiegen würde.
Was es jetzt nicht ausschließt, ist, dass du dich trotzdem woanders mal umguckst.
Vielleicht findest du ja auch was, was dir wirklich gut gefällt,
wo du sagst, hey, das ist ähnlich nice oder mach zumindest einen ähnlich guten Eindruck.
Man weiß ja nie, was man dann wirklich am Ende bekommt.
In der Bewerbung sieht das oftmals ja alles viel geiler aus, als es am Ende ist.
Ich mache mir da auch keine Illusion, dass dort in die Versicherung, wo ich jetzt wechsle,
dass dort alles perfekt sein wird, auch wenn es sich gut angehört hat.
Es gibt immer Sachen, die dich aufregen.
Aber du solltest dich jetzt nicht von Abhalt nicht mal umzukucken.
Es spricht ja wirklich nichts dagegen.
Und wenn du was findest, was dir gefällt und mehr Geld bezahlt,
vielleicht ist es ja auch was.
Und ich meine, vielleicht kannst du damit sogar
noch ein bisschen mehr Geld raushandeln bei deinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber,
wo dir alles so gut gefällt und da bleibt.
Aber wenn es dir gefällt und das Geld nicht brauchst
und so rund um zufrieden bist, auch mit deinem Gehalt,
musst du einfach auch gar nichts machen.
Erfreue dich des Lebens und sei happy.
Und mach dir nicht so viele Gedanken,
dass du irgendwo 20 Prozent mehr kriegen könntest.
Fake-Git-History.
Das kannst du auch machen.
Das Problem ist nur, dass in Fake-Git-History halt nichts drin ist.
Sinnvolles an Projekten.
Vier-Tage-Woche ist tatsächlich was, was ich jedem empfehlen kann,
wenn es den Gehaltsverlust, wenn man das irgendwie aushält.
Vier-Tage-Woche ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Das ist zwar nur einen Tag mehr frei,
aber der wiegt viel mehr als einen Tag.
Habe ich mir schon oft darüber ausgelassen.
Ja, das ist bei allen, die labern alle Blödsinn.
Wie gesagt, gute Führungskräfte sind rar gesehen.
Mir ist gerade was runtergefallen,
was nicht gut ist, dass mir es runtergefallen ist,
weil es ist wirklich doof,
habe ich mein Handy mit der Lampe,
weil wenn ich da drauf trete,
da ist es, so ein Stück Draht.
Ich muss mal kurz unter den Tisch krabbeln.
Wenn ich da drauf trete bzw. das irgendwie mit meinem Fuß rumschiebe,
dann habe ich es wieder im Fuß stecken.
Hattet ihr schon mal einen Jumperkabel oder so einen Pinheader?
Hattet ihr schon mal einen Pinheader im Fußzeh stecken?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich kann euch auch nicht raten, das zu machen.
Muss mal auszuprobieren.
Ich meine sowas hier.
Also ich gehe davon aus,
die meisten von euch klingt richtig dumm.
Ja, ist es auch.
Ist es auch.
Das ist richtig dumm.
Ja, sowas passiert zum Beispiel,
wenn ihr an eurem Schreibtisch auch ein bisschen rum bastelt
und euch fällt sowas runter
und irgendwann sitzt ihr da vielleicht mit Socken oder nackischen Füßen sogar
und wedelt mit euren Füßen unter dem Tisch auf dem Teppich rum
und das Ding verkantet sich und ihr habt es auf einmal im Zeh stecken
oder in der Ferse.
In der Ferse hatte ich es.
Stimmt gar nicht.
Ich hatte es in der Ferse, nicht im Zeh.
In der Ferse stecken.
Und das hat ein ganz ekliches Geräusch gemacht.
Man hat so richtig das Reißen der Haut gehört.
Das hat richtig lautes, lauter so alles gemacht.
Und in dem Moment, wo ich dieses Geräusch gehört habe, wusste ich,
fuck, in circa 250 Millisekunden tut es weh.
Also ich habe das schneller gehört und den, den,
ich habe die Berührung und den Sound schneller gespürt, als es weh getan hat.
Also es ist nicht schön sowas.
Es macht keinen Spaß.
Es ist jetzt keine krasse Verletzung, wo du ins Krankenhaus musst,
aber das ist unangenehm, sowas im Fuß stecken zu haben.
Wie sind wir jetzt noch mal davon auf Pinheader im Fuß stecken gekommen?
Ach so, weil mir der Draht runtergefallen ist, genau.
Deshalb Sicherheitsschuhe, hast du Sicherheitsschuhe daheim am Schreibtisch an?
Nee, du kannst Zwischenzeugnisse beantragen.
Das muss dir dein Arbeitgeber zwar nicht ausstellen,
aber es gibt bestimmte Ereignisse, da steht ja eins zu.
Zum Beispiel vorgesetzten Wechsel oder Führungskräftewechsel.
Oder aber, und das ist das, wo der Arbeitgeber relativ schlecht ablehnen kann,
ist Aufgabengebiet, Gebietsänderungen, Erweiterungen.
Und nachdem sich in der IT die Aufgabengebiete laufen, irgendwie erweitern und ändern,
ist es relativ easy, damit Arbeitzeugnisse kriegen.
Wirst du eigentlich Hogwarts Legacy spielen?
Okay, ich werde es nicht spielen.
Und nicht, weil es Leute triggern würde, sondern weil mich Harry Potter nicht interessiert.
Wobei ich bei dem ganzen Rumgeflame auf Twitter kurzzeitig den Reflex verspürt habe,
es als reine Trotzreaktion zu kaufen.
Es war mir dann doch nicht interessant genug, dass ich es mir doch gekauft hätte.
Und mittlerweile musst du ja schon Angst haben,
wenn du da spielst, dass irgendwie eine Horde Leute um die Ecke kommt und dich belästigt.
Flex auf Twitter streamen, genau.
Ich kaufe mir doch kein Game, was ich gar kein Interesse habe zu spielen.
Ein Cobol-Compiler.
Oh ja, das ist nice, das brauche ich unbedingt.
Otterkit. Otterkit Cobol-Compiler.
Free Open Source Compiler for Cobol.
.NET Plattform.
Nice Leute, ich wollte schon immer mal Cobol auf.NET haben.
Patrick, da hast du recht.
Das ist wirklich lustig, ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Ich würde nicht sagen kurz davor, aber ich habe so das Verlangen verspürt.
Okay, man kann wirklich Cobol auf.
Warum nicht?
Es gibt sicherlich die ein oder anderen 85 jährigen Cobol-Fans.
Ja, genau so sieht es aus.
Habe ich auch letztens schon im Stream erzählt, das ist der beste Tipp, den man geben kann, wenn man Zwischenzeugnis haben will.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wenn die Firma eine gute Kantine hat, gehe ich jeden Tag dahin.
Selbst dann würde ich nicht jeden Tag in die Firma.
Wir haben eine ganz gute Kantine, die auch subventioniert ist.
Es kostet trotzdem noch ein bisschen Geld, es ist nicht komplett umsonst, aber ich gehe trotzdem nicht jeden Tag in die Firma.
MIT und Cambridge, ich glaube, das ist für die meisten hier in Deutschland eher nicht das, was sie machen wollen.
Klar, wenn du den krassen Karriere-Krime machen willst und das Krime-Mindset hast, dann mach das.
Da musst du aber auch erstmal aufgenommen werden und dann ist mit in Deutschland bleiben nichts erstmal.
Abab, ist das SAP?
Ach, er hat nach Krime-Unis gefragt.
Abab ist SAP.
Damit kann man gut Geld verdienen.
Ich habe auch schon von einigen SAP-Consultants gehört, die fette Kohle mit heim schleppen.
Also es mag jetzt bestimmt nicht das geilste zum entwickeln sein, aber geldtechnisch ist es bestimmt nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe gehört, dass HL7-Entwickler dringend gesucht werden.
Leute, ich gebe es zu.
Damit ich nicht total dumm dastehe, habe ich offscreen gerade gegoogelt, was HL7 ist.
Ich wollte natürlich einen obligatorischen Half-Life-Joke bringen, aber der ist mittlerweile ausgelutscht.
Das ist irgendein Standard zum Austausch zwischen Medizin-Plattformen, habe ich gelesen.
Mehr weiß ich nicht.
Wenn ein neuer Kollege kommt, bekommt man der in der Regel deutlich mehr Kohle.
Das spricht aber nicht unbedingt für die Firma, wenn sie auf die bestehenden Leute scheißen und den neuen massig viel Geld geben.
Die müssen den neuen heute viel mehr bieten, aber man sollte sich auch mal überlegen,
möchte man da nicht die Leute halten, die schon da sind und Ahnung vom System haben.
Weil egal wie gut Dokumentation ist, wie gut die Prozesse sind, wie gut das Projektmanagement ist,
es wird immer Kopfwissen geben und Leute, die nach Jahren gehen und viel mitbekommen haben,
sind immer ein Verlust für die Firma, egal wie gut der Rest drumherum ist.
Das heißt, es wäre bescheuert, auf die bestehenden Leute zu kacken und da nichts zu machen.
Aber gut, vielleicht sagt die Firma halt aus, kann ja auch sein.
Man sollte das so machen wie dieser Python-Typ heute auf Twitter.
Man sollte einfach immer nur die Sachen verwenden, die gut sind und dann ist es kein Problem mehr.
Und ich meine, keine Fehler programmieren hat schon mal einen großen Vorteil.
Man braucht auch keine Tests, man braucht auch keine Dokumentation und keine Comments.
Einfach keine Fehler mehr, just forehead, einfach keine Fehler programmieren.
Holy Lucky Gamers, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Zweiter Monat, Poggers, bald hast du den ersten Keks unlockt.
Obwohl, ich glaube, du hast schon den zweiten Keks unlockt.
Das erste ist ja der Holzkeks Holzliga.
Tja, naja, gut, ich kann dir sagen, wie es aktuell bei uns läuft.
Also dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, die haben ihren Anspruch so weit runtergeschraubt,
dass sie in Positionen, wo es eigentlich mit um Lidungsadministration geht,
mittlerweile Leute einstellen, die keine Lidungserfahrung haben.
So, und dann halt auch Leute, die vielleicht nicht unbedingt die allergrößte Motivation haben,
was zu lernen.
Wann gibt es neue Emotes?
Neue Emotes gab es erst vor einem Monat oder so.
Ein paar neue Emotes.
Aber es muss neue Badges geben, da hast du recht.
Und die tun sich wirklich schwer.
Die haben nicht wirklich viel Bock, sich mit Lidungs auseinanderzusetzen.
Und dort weiß ich nicht, ob er die Probezeit übersteht.
Aber letztendlich kann sich die Firma wahrscheinlich auch nicht leisten.
Hat jemand eine gute Methode, um seine Tabs aufzuräumen?
Bei mir hat sich ein bisschen was angesammelt.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht draufklicken, weil ich die Vorschau mir nicht angucken kann.
Ah, nee, hier.
Okay, zeig mal, wie viele Tabs hast du?
So viele Tabs hast du doch gar nicht.
Oh, das ist gefotoshopt, oder?
Das hast du über Photoshop.
Denn die einfachste Variante ist ja immer noch die hier.
Aber das wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht wollen.
Du willst ja wahrscheinlich ein paar Sachen dir merken.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, einfach nicht aufräumen und weitermachen.
Für irgendwas braucht man ja seinen Arbeitsspeicher.
Guck dir mal, das ist traurig.
Leute, es ist traurig.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Moment.
Warum habe ich 31 Dick in use?
Ich habe nichts offen.
Ich lecke critical information über meinen Rechner, glaube ich.
Ich habe die VM offen.
Aber die VM braucht auch nicht so viel.
Die VM braucht 5G.
Ach, cached.
Okay, ich habe nur 12 belegt.
Das macht mehr Sinn.
Ich habe nur 12 belegt.
Aber es ist trotzdem armselig.
Guck mal hier.
Ich habe trotzdem zwei laufenden VMs und Chrome Tabs.
Ich habe nur die Hälfte meines RAMs belegt.
Da geht noch was.
Da geht noch ordentlich.
Nur die Hälfte ist voll.
Das Video mache ich demnächst.
Mit Bewerbung, Skill-Liste und Job-Suche.
Morgen gibt es ein Video zur Emulator-Kiste.
Richtig gut geschnitten ist vom Tyler.
Der hat mein Gelaber zusammengeschnitten.
Nicht aus dem Stream.
Ich habe noch zusätzlich etwas eingesprochen.
Richtig gut gemacht.
Lässt sich nice angucken.
Wäre es nicht super mega geil, wenn man einen Lebenslauf als Web-App hat?
Prinzipiell ja.
Das Problem ist nur, dass du damit rechnen musst, dass die Personalabteilung keine Ahnung
von Technik hat.
Und es eventuell irgendwelche internen Workflows gibt, wo die Bewerbungen als PDFs ausgetauscht
werden.
Oder als Dokumente ausgetauscht werden.
Das heißt an sich eine coole Idee.
Praktisch vielleicht schwierig je nach Firma.
Machst du noch Videos über Stellen ausschreiben?
Ich würde gerne Feedback zu unserer erhalten.
Ich habe noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit.
Also wenn du die hier öffentlich posten willst und die in Verbindung bringen kannst, kannst
du einfach in Chat posten.
Wir können die gleich mal angucken.
Dann kann es natürlich auch sein, dass der Chat sich ein bisschen darüber auslässt.
Aber der Chat ist ja meistens vollkommen harmlos.
Stimmt's?
Was ich als Simpel...
Ja kann man machen.
Achja nice.
Auch gleich im Doppelpack.
Das ist natürlich dann...
Doppel nice.
Wo war das mit Doppel plus gut?
War das 1984, wo Doppel plus gut eigentlich eine Umschreibung war für irgendwas anderes?
Kriegste nicht mal genau zusammen.
Doppel plus gut.
C Doppel plus oh please.
So habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen.
Also zum Thema...
Es steht drin, dass sie ein Studium wollen, da steht oftmals viel Käse drin in Stellenanzeigen.
Meistens steht ja drin Studium oder Ausbildung oder vergleichbare Ausbildung oder bla bla bla.
Ganz ehrlich, es ist scheiß egal, wenn du Berufserfahrungen hast, ob du ein Studium
oder eine Ausbildung gemacht hast.
Guck mal, ich mache den Kram jetzt seit 15 Jahren.
Das geht denen sonst wo vorbei, ob ich ein Studium gemacht habe oder eine Ausbildung,
solange ich das kann, was die haben wollen.
Was vielleicht keinen Unterschied macht, ist, wenn du vielleicht Beamter werden willst oder
irgendwie was mit öffentlichem...
Wie heißt das?
TV, TV-ÖD?
Wie heißt diese komische Tarifgeschichte dort?
Da macht es vielleicht einen Unterschied.
Da habe ich ja gerade schon beantwortet.
Kann ich das anklicken?
Ich habe das nur angeklickt, weil du das geschrieben hast.
Ich weiß, dass du schon öfters hier bist, noch nie debatet hast.
Ja, das wird so kommen.
Wer weiß, was in 40 Jahren die Halbsprache ist.
Ich meine 40 Jahre könnte ich mitkriegen, da bin ich 78.
Link habe ich gesehen, ich bin gleich irgendwann demnächst soweit.
Da ist das Ding, der Stuhl.
Oh doch, ich schon.
Ich habe bei uns schon Leute gesehen, die die Probezeit nicht überstanden haben.
Ich habe sogar Externe gesehen, die nach zwei Wochen wieder weg waren.
Weil sie zwei Wochen lang gebraucht haben, um ihr Notebook einzurichten.
Wir hatten teilweise schon Leute bei uns als externe Experten.
Wo die Frage, wo der Experte drin stecken soll, habe ich auch nicht verstanden.
So, ist das deine?
Ist das deine?
Quatsch, du heißt ja Patrick, das kannst du nicht sein.
Was bin ich da sehen?
Sieht eigentlich gar nicht übel aus.
Ach, das ist dein Bruder.
Also, finde ich euch ganz hübsch, sieht halt sehr technisch aus.
Weiß nicht, ob das die Personalabteilung anspricht.
Okay, also, Wunderpunkt Software, Job.
Mach das mal kurz in der Vorschau auf, man weiß ja nie.
Okay, alles klar, legit.
Oh, wisst ihr, was ich schon mal sehr gut finde?
Dark Theme, wenn man Dark Mode im Browser aktiviert hat.
Ohne Dark Reader, das sammelt bei mir schon mal Pluspunkte, Leute.
Findet ihr es nicht auch ausgesprochen, dass es Dark Theme hat,
wenn man Dark im Betriebssystem und im Browser eingestellt hat?
Weil ich habe es gerade bei mir im Browser aufgemacht.
Dort ist es Light Theme, also, sprich, guckt ihr, Achtung, Brille, Leute, Brille.
Sonnenbrille.
Es ist nice, das ist gut, das finde ich schon mal schön.
So, okay, Senior Frontenentwickler und Entwicklerin.
Attraktives Gehalt ab 4500 Euro.
Das finde ich schon mal exzellent, dass das drin steht.
Man weiß zwar natürlich nicht, ob es 12 Monats Gelder, 13 oder 14 Monats Gelder sind,
aber ich vermute mal, dass ich so ausgerechnet habe, dass es wahrscheinlich 12 sind.
Würde ich jetzt mal von ausgehen.
Ich würde es ja so rechnen, dass es möglichst gut klingt.
Das finde ich schon mal nice, dass das so drin steht.
Plus Boni.
Weiß man ja nicht, was es da alles gibt, aber das ist doch schon mal gut, dass es da steht.
Ich meine, super krass viel ist es jetzt nett.
Das sind 12 Mal.
Das sind 54K.
Das ist jetzt...
Ich weiß nicht, ich kenne die Region nicht.
Für einen Senior Entwickler, ich denke, das ist durchaus okay, aber das ist jetzt nicht
super ins Fähren, dass jetzt jeder sich darum reißt.
Also, gerade wenn es eine Senior Position ist und dementsprechend auch Leute mit viel
Berufserfahrung sucht, ist das jetzt schon nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Aber gut, ich meine, letztendlich ist es eure Stellanzeige.
Ihr müsst ja wissen, was ihr da für Budget habt.
Ich würde bloß sagen, für mich wäre es jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen wenig.
Es kommt natürlich darauf an, es sei denn, es sind mega, mega krasse Boni.
Kann ja auch sein, dass es sich dann alles wieder ausgleicht.
Budget für Weiterbildung und Zertifizierung.
Okay, das ist natürlich schon mal ein richtig großer Pluspunkt.
100% Remote, vor allem, dass das auch so drin steht.
100% Remote in unserem, in unserer Region.
Co-Working Space in deiner Nähe.
Ja, also 100% Remote finde ich gut, dass ihr das gleich so offensiv reinschreibt.
Da weiß man nämlich Bescheid.
Zumal man sagen muss, für viele Leute, das denke ich, auch je nach Gewichtung,
Homeoffice was, was durchaus mehr zählt als vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Geld.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es Leute gibt, die sagen,
ey, da verzichte ich sogar auf ein bisschen Kohle, wenn ich 100% Homeoffice machen kann.
Also finde ich gut, dass das gleich offensiv so drin steht.
Ja gut, stimmt, das steht ab davor, aber das ab, letztendlich kann mir nach der Zahl gehen, die da steht.
Top Hardware und Freie, das finde ich auch super, dass ihr das reinschreibt.
Also die Top Hardware ist ja Definitionsfrage, aber freie Betriebssystemauswahl, das finde ich eine super Geschichte.
Das wäre für mich ein sehr großer Pluspunkt, kann ich euch gleich sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, chat, wie ihr das seht, für mich wäre das ein großer Pluspunkt.
Ich meine, ich würde es nicht machen, wenn, das wäre jetzt kein Pluspunkt, wenn ich keinen Bock drauf hätte,
aus anderen Gründen zu sagen, ja deswegen mache ich es, aber obendrauf nochmal ist das eine super Geschichte.
Homeoffice Setup, das ist auch gut, ja.
Keine Schmerzen, mein Rechner ist dafür zu verwenden, aber wenn...
Freie Arbeitszeitwahl, wir haben virtuelle Termine, meistens nach Scrum, den Rest der Zeit kannst du selbstverantwortlich organisieren.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie ich es deuten würde, kann natürlich auch heißen, dass es recht verplant ist, wenn es da keinen gibt, der Sachen organisiert.
Also ich würde es wahrscheinlich kritisch auslegen, wie es so geschrieben ist.
Ich kann jetzt ja immer nur sagen, wie es so auf mich spontan wirkt, ja, das soll jetzt nicht heißen, dass ich das irgendwie schlecht machen will.
Das ist jetzt bis hierhin schon besser als die meisten anderen Stellenzeuge, die ich so sehe, ja, so ist es nicht.
Ich kann ja immer nur sagen, wie es auf mich fängt.
Auf mich wird sich ein bisschen, das ist ja gut, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, aber wenn ich alles selbst organisieren muss und planen muss,
dann stellt sich bei mir so die Frage, ja, also gibt es denn dann überhaupt irgendjemand, der dort ein bisschen was organisiert,
weil ich bin ja IT-Experte und kein Manager.
Offene und Lebenskultur siehe Werte, arbeite an Software mit Teams in Größe von des OK.
Was erwartet dich? Wir sind ein Team aus talentierten und hoch motivierten Software Experten,
welches gemeinsam mit unseren Kunden Software skalierbar und nachhaltig entwickelt.
Unsere Projekte laufen mindestens drei Monate, im Normalfall jedoch.
Ist das eigentlich unbefristet?
Das sehe ich, habe ich jetzt nichts zu gesehen.
Wenn ja, würde ich das noch reinschreiben.
Unsere Laufen mindestens, gefällt dir ein Projekt, ich finde mal ein alternatives Projekt für dich.
Okay.
You build it, you run it.
Wir arbeiten in Interdisziplinarität, setzen dabei auf starke DevOps-Kulturen, um schneller und stärker auf Veränderungen Anforderungen zu geben.
Unser Tech-Stack.
Für unsere Lösungen setzen wir auf verschiedene. Wie soll denn ein Frontend-Engineer es auch komplett runnen?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Also ich bin ja immer dafür, dass man sagt, man sollte über den Tellerrand hinaus schauen.
Und man sollte auch als Anwendungsentwickler sich ein bisschen um die Serverseite kümmern.
Und auch als Admin sich ein bisschen mit Anwendungsentwicklung auseinandersetzen.
Aber dass jetzt ein Frontend-Entwickler sich komplett um den Betrieb der Anwendung kümmert, umfassend,
vielleicht jetzt, ich weiß ja nicht, wie es gemeint ist, vielleicht nicht so hundertprozentig in den Titel entsprechend, oder?
Für unsere Software, für unsere Lösungen setzen wir auch verschiedene Technologien.
Folgend ein Ausdruck aus Tech-Stacks aktueller Projekte.
React.js Vue.js, damit werdet ihr schon mal auf viel Freude, Begeisterung stoßen.
Es gibt natürlich noch bessere, krassere Hype-Frameworks jetzt,
aber es muss ja auch irgendwas sein, was business-technisch schon etabliert ist.
Das werden auf jeden Fall genug Leute finden, die es mögen.
Auch, auch, warum sind das alles drei?
Da hätte ich jetzt ein bisschen ein Fragezeichen über den Kopf, warum es alle drei sind.
War ich da nicht eins?
Typescript, Tailwind, CSS, CraftQL, Node.js.
Gut, Node.js, ja klar, die ganzen Tools für Frontend sind in Node.js.
Ach, verschiedene, ach so, dafür sucht ihr Leute, okay.
Also sprich, es ist nicht so, dass ihr das, es ist nicht so, dass ihr in einen Auftrag kommt,
entwickelt das mal für uns, sondern es ist eher so, dass ihr eure Kunden unterstützt beim Entwickeln
und dementsprechend auch denen ihre Infrastruktur und Git-Server und sowas mitverwendet.
Ja.
Was wir erwarten.
Unsere neuen Kollegen erwarten wir eine proaktive und offene Kommunikation gegenüber unseren Kollegen.
Okay, ja.
Das könnt ihr auch erwarten, das glaube ich nicht so gut, wenn das erste ist, was man hört,
so nach dem Motto, Alter, warum muss ich euch einen Kack programmieren?
Sollte man eigentlich erwarten.
Wir suchen Entwicklerinnen mit langjähriger Erfahrung in der Umsetzung von Web-Anwendungen.
Ja, gut, ist ja eine Senior-Stelle, vollkommen legitim.
Dabei hast du bereits Erfahrungen im Internet.
Das ist übrigens auch was, was ich von der Senior-Position erwarten würde.
Deswegen finde ich es auch vollkommen richtig, da reinzuschreiben.
Eine Senior-Position würde ich auch erwarten, dass sie nicht nur fachlich gut was drauf haben
und zumindest das zusätzlich auch noch ganz gut vertreten und verkaufen können.
Wir suchen Entwicklerinnen, also Senior-Leute, das ist auch immer jemand, wo ich sagen würde,
den kann man in ein übergreifendes Meeting schicken, der dann quasi die Interessen des Teams vertritt dort.
Muss ja nicht unbedingt immer der Chef machen, gerade wenn es ist was, wo man technisch ein bisschen Ahnung haben muss.
So würde ich das halt auch bei einer Senior-Stelle sehen.
Und ja, deswegen muss ich ein bisschen...
Ai, ai, ai, ai, ai.
Übertreib es nicht, ich hätte es mir auch so angeguckt.
Aber trotzdem, danke, danke, danke für die ganzen Subs.
Bin auch noch nicht fertig, pass mal auf.
Okay, jetzt sind die Prime-Subs drinne, jetzt kann ich anfangen zu flamen.
Jetzt geht es los, Leute.
Okay, lass uns kurz fertig lesen.
Wir suchen Entwicklerinnen...
Danke, danke.
Habt ihr irgendeine Anforderung?
Ich meine, das ist ja eine Senior-Stelle.
Habt ihr irgendeine Anforderung an...
Irgendeine, ein bisschen konkretere Anforderung an Erfahrung?
Ich meine, okay, wir suchen...
Wobei, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Das ist eigentlich gut, wenn man so ein bisschen Waage lässt.
Ich glaube, das finde ich sogar so viel besser, wie es ist.
Ihr sucht ja letztendlich Leute, die Ahnung haben, Leute, die Plan haben.
Das kann nach 15 Jahren sein, das kann aber auch nach 5 Jahren sein.
Und die halt auch die anderen Sachen alle mitbringen.
Ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Also ich finde die Anzeige besser als das meiste.
Guck mal, da ist... Guck mal hier.
Live editiert, Leute.
Poggers.
Höchst agil.
Ich hoffe, das kommt morgen auch im Daily Scrum dran.
Und der Task wurde im Kann-Man-Board auch ordentlich verschoben dafür.
Ja, nice.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist besser als die meisten Stellenanzeigen.
Das, was ich hier erzählt habe, ist jetzt ja wirklich nur ein bisschen...
So Knitpicking oder so.
Bin ich insgesamt in Ordnung? Passt.
Falls ihr wirklich da auch mehr ausgeben wollt,
vielleicht könnte man auch ein bisschen mehr hinschreiben,
aber ich verstehe es schon, dass man eine Hausnummer sagen will,
dass die Leute...
Also ich denke mal, so die Intention von euch war folgende.
Ihr wolltet da eine gewisse Hausnummer hinschreiben,
dass die Leute sich bewerben, dass die Leute sehen,
okay, hier gibt es auch was zu holen.
Ihr wolltet allerdings nicht mega das Ding hinschreiben,
dass es einen gewissen Verhandlungsspielraum einfach gibt.
So in der Richtung stelle ich mir das vor.
Und deswegen denke ich, geht das auch so vollkommen in Ordnung.
Also da wird eh keiner...
Also hoffe ich mal, eh keiner denken...
Steht ab 4500, da wird eh keiner denken, ist Schluss.
Da wird sich dann auch jemand bewerben,
der vielleicht eine Vorstellung hat, keine Ahnung, 70k, 80k,
und das dann sagen, und dann kann man sich ja der Sache
ein bisschen annähern, ja.
Genau Patrick, sehe ich auch so.
Ich dachte am Anfang auch, ist ja nicht so viel,
aber als Verhandlungsgrundlage ist das vollkommen super, ja.
Nice, und danke schön für die ganzen Subs.
Ich überskippe, ich skippe das mal.
Aber schön Chat, dass ihr mitgemacht habt.
Wer hat eigentlich, also die Hälfte hat wieder gedodged.
Habt ihr wieder schön die Subscriptions evaded.
Dodge, ja beiß, du bist wieder dran vorbei.
Vielleicht ist das auch noch was, was man reinschreiben könnte.
Teilzeit und Vollzeit möglich, das vielleicht auch nicht verkehrt.
Das würde mich jetzt persönlich natürlich interessieren,
weil ich arbeite ja auch nur Teilzeit.
Ich arbeite auch nur vier Tage, also wenn das möglich ist,
ist das auch noch ein guter Pluspunkt, den man reinschreiben kann.
Alter, jetzt kommt da Patrick um die Ecke,
muss er ein Schweizer Gehalt irgendwie ausgeben.
Danke schön für die ganzen Subs, 10 Stück.
Nee, beiß hat immer noch gedodged, wieder gedodged.
Danke für die Subs.
Poggers, hat sich heute ja wieder richtig gelohnt zu streamen.
Komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch irgendein interessantes Video
zum ins Bett gehen an.
22 Uhr muss ich pennen, morgen wieder auf die Arbeit.
So, was können wir uns angucken, was haben wir zu bieten?
Intel versus AMD, wer ist besser?
Macht endlich Schluss mit den Fanboys.
Alles klar.
Leute, Leute, ist ja gut, ist ja gut.
Nochmal schön, beiß, Poggers, so muss das sein.
Danke Patrick und Leku, danke schön.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, wie man das richtig ausspricht.
Du hast mir schon fünfmal erzählt.
Aber der ist open source, das heißt wir können das eh.
Ich mache Pullgequest auf.
Okay, wie man das fürs Ü kommen soll,
erschließt sich mir jetzt wirklich nicht.
Danke schön.
Das hier, Wirtschaftsinformatik-Job-Einstieg.
Mein IT-Startup, Alpha-Uni.
Okay, Leute, das gucken wir.
Vorschlag aus dem Chat, ist so viele Leute jetzt gegiftet.
Jetzt gucken wir mal einen Vorschlag aus dem Chat.
Save Schweizer, machen die das so mit dem Ü?
Serious Max hat, das habe ich heute offen,
das gucken wir uns irgendwann anders an.
Dieses angucken.
Okay, aber ganz schnell jetzt.
Wieso ist das, ist das was von dir?
Oder hast du was mit denen zu tun?
Okay, kein Dark Mode, geht schon mal schlecht los.
ICT Support Engineer, Second Level für Clouds und IT Services, MW.
Warum nur männlich weiß, warum nicht auch noch deutsch?
Ah, weil es in der Schweiz ist.
Es müsste eigentlich MWS sein.
80 bis 100.
Okay, die Slynet AG ist ein dynamisches und erfolgreiches
Schweizer IT-Unternehmen.
Zur Verstärkung des Support Teams für unsere stetig wachsenden
Business Cloud und IT Service suchen wir am Standard LUPFIG.
Okay, ich kenne mich in der Schweiz nicht aus,
aber davon habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ein enger engagiertes und motiviertes neues Teammitglied
für unseren Team Betrieb und Support.
Betriebs und Support, darf ich mal raten,
das sind welche, die Schichtarbeit machen müssen
und 24-7 da sein?
Ist das mit Schichtarbeit?
Falls ja, finden das schwierig Leute zu finden,
die Bock drauf haben.
Kann ich euch als eigene Erfahrung von uns sagen.
Ohne Gehalt, ja.
Aber ich gehöre, die Schweizer machen das mit Gehalt
eigentlich ganz gerne.
So, als ICT-Support.
Was ist denn ICT?
IT Communi...
Nee.
Was ist ICT?
Information und Tele...
Okay, dann lag ich doch nicht so verkehrt.
Als ICT-Support Engineer 2nd Level
unterstützen Sie unseren Helpdesk und Kunden
bei Aufgaben und Störungsfällen und Überzeugungen
als kompetenter Ansprechpartner.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie vor Ort
kleine Server-Netzwerksysteme in Betrieb
und übernehmen vereinzelte Tage im Helpdesk.
Nein, Gott!
Nein, Gott, bitte nein!
Nein!
Was soll ich herumPrime daar nach irgendwas geben?
Etwas zu викerosen.
Because behind the scenes,
das wäre für mich ausschluss-Kriterium
Mensch, das ist Gag dabei...
Gagbei...
Da hätte ich wirklich kein Bock drauf,
absolut gar nicht.
Izukin...
Leko, warum fragst du?
Willst du dich dort bewerben oder
... da arbeitest du dort?
Sie organisieren sich selbst und sind zuständig für die Qualifizierung und Priorisierung von entgegengenommenen Störungen und Supportfällen.
Ja, okay, hätte ich jetzt gedacht.
Diese bearbeiten sie im Rahmen ihrer...
... Kenntnisse weitgehend selbst. Okay, bla bla bla.
Bei Bedarf erhalten sie Unterstützung von... Okay, bla bla bla.
Weiter planen und bearbeiten sie Aufgaben im Rahmen von Kundenaufträgen teilweise oder vollständig selbst.
Dazu gehören unter anderem die Planung in Betrieb neuer Kundenstandorte und das Einrichten von Cloud...
Das Einrichten von Cloud-Lösungen.
Also viel unspezifischer kann es jetzt ja wirklich nicht mehr sein.
Das ist ja...
Ich mach was mit Computer.
Das ist jetzt das einzige, wie du das noch steigern kannst. Ich mach was mit Computer.
Nach ihrer umfassenden Einarbeitung erhalten sie...
Okay, wenn ihr das wirklich so meint, ist gut, aber...
Ich weiß das, dass es nicht oft passiert, weil...
So was Ähnliches steht dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, auch in der Stellanzeige.
Und die Einarbeitung ist grottenschlecht...
... nicht existent zum Glück.
Nicht existent zum größten Teil.
Nach ihrer umfassenden Einarbeitung erhalten sie die Möglichkeit, schrittweise die technische Betriebsverantwortung...
... für verschiedene auf Cloud-Technologien beziehende Lösungen zu bedienen.
Die Betriebsverantwortung?
Du bist Support?
Warum hast du als Support die Verantwortung für irgendwas?
Also...
Ich kenn's von uns.
Ich versuch das mal zu umschreiben.
Ich kenn das von uns. Wir haben einen 24-7-Support.
Bei uns.
Und die haben auch die, wie man so schön nennt, Betriebsverantwortung.
Was damit allerdings nur gemeint ist...
... bei uns. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es bei euch ist.
Dadurch, dass die quasi sich um die Überwachung kümmern...
... und um Überwachung, Monitorung, Eskalation von Störungen...
... das Einzige, was bei uns damit gemeint ist, ist...
... dass die Überwartungsarbeiten...
... dass die Wartungsarbeiten abnicken müssen.
Die müssen informiert werden, Überwartungsarbeiten...
... müssen die quasi zur Kenntnis nehmen und abnehmen.
Viel anderes ist aber uns damit nicht gemeint.
Weil selbstverständlich kann der Support nicht dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden...
... wenn neue Anwendungsversionen deployed werden, die den Bug haben.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Wie du dir einen Schichtdienst vorstellen kannst...
... meistens aus einer Kombination Frühschicht, Tagsüberschicht und Spätschicht...
... beziehungsweise Nachtschicht.
Also sowas von, sagen wir mal...
... 6 bis 13 Uhr, 13 Uhr bis irgendwie 21 Uhr...
... und dann, keine Ahnung, 21 Uhr bis 6 Uhr...
... oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen vertan mit den Zeiten wahrscheinlich...
... aber sowieso in der Richtung.
Kannst du dir Schichtbetrieb vorstellen?
Und dann wechselnd auch, also sprich...
... dass du dann mal 3 Tage so, 3 Tage so, 3 Tage so...
... und dann wieder ein bisschen frei...
... und dann wieder von vorne oder wie auch immer der Schichtplan ist...
... ist auf jeden Fall nicht für jeden was.
Okay, also nachher...
... Qualifikation, Informatiker EFZ...
... das ist irgendein Schweizer Ding...
... ich habe keine Ahnung was ein EFZ Informatiker ist...
... mit mindestens 3 Jahren Berufserfahrung...
... und entsprechende Queransteiger bereit...
... was?
Was? Nicht...
... breit abgestütztes Informatik Fachwissen...
... im Microsoft System und Cloud Umfeld, okay...
... eigenständige Lösungsfindung durch...
... analytisch und strukturiert Arbeitsweise...
... hohe Lernbereitschaft, reiche Auffassungsgabe...
... Kenntnis in den Bereichen Microsoft 365...
... Windows Server, Client, Remote, Desktop, Umgebung, Active Directory...
... Virtualisierungslösungen sowie IP-Netzung gut...
... das ist ja mal auch der komplette Rundumschlag...
... weil Virtualisierungslösung ist ein so breites Feld...
... dass du dafür ganze Abteilungen haben kannst...
... genauso wie Netzwerk...
... ähm gut, muss man dann halt im Detail gucken...
... was ist, was es ist...
... Freude am direkten Kundenkontakt...
Nein Gott!
Piss dich also!
Bitte nein!
Ach, Berufbereitschaft ist das!
Ach so!
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm!
Kommt auf die, kommt auf den Umfang an!
Nee!
Damit ist bestimmt nicht 24-7 am Handy gemeint!
Also wenn das so ist...
... wenn das so ist, ist...
Ach so, ja doch, ist das...
Das ist doof!
Also 24-7 am Handy bereit ist doof!
Also wenn das eingeteilt ist, dass du das...
... was weiß ich...
... so im Team, dass irgendwie jeder mal ran muss...
... 2, 3 mal im Jahr für eine Woche...
... finde ich das vollkommen in Ordnung!
Aber wenn es natürlich immer permanent ist...
... dann ist es kacke!
Es ist alle 6 Wochen!
Ja, damit könnte man vielleicht auch noch leben!
Nee!
Seriously Leute!
Je nachdem wie gut der Laden aufgestellt ist...
... ist Berufbereitschaft jetzt nicht unbedingt so...
... als super kritisch zu sehen!
Erstens, genau, erstens kriegt man Geld dafür...
... und in Deutschland ist es so, dass Bereitschaftsgeld...
... ein bisschen weniger...
... also man muss weniger Steuern drauf bezahlen...
... und wenn der Laden gut aufgestellt ist...
... sodass in der Bereitschaft so gut wie nichts passiert...
... kann sich das wirklich lohnen, ohne dass das jetzt...
... ein super krasser Stress ist!
Stil, sicheres Deutsch...
... sowie Verständigung in Englisch...
... Französisch kennt er gut, wir sind in der Schweiz...
... teamorientiertes Arbeit mit Fahnen und Pflichtbussen...
... okay, relativ 0 auf 15...
... relativ 0 auf 15 die Stellenanzeige...
... das ist jetzt nicht wo ich sagen würde, oh krass...
... also bei mir, ich wäre eh schon raus mit...
... mit Kundenkontakt und sowas, aber...
... Helpdesk...
Leute, komm wir gucken uns jetzt schnell das Video noch an...
... meine wir schaffen das noch...
... Achtung...
... komm wir haben ein bisschen...
... im Zweifelsfall überziehen wir...
... also Wirtschaftsinformatik, Jobeinstieg...
... mein IT-Startup...
... App in den App-Store abbringen...
... ich bin jetzt schon seit 2 Stunden hier...
... und es ist schon einiges schief gegangen...
... und es funktioniert immer noch nicht...
... ähnlich mal jemand mit richtiger Informatikerfigur...
... das heißt, das war schon mal nicht der Fehler...
... wir wollen möglich machen, dass der Trainer...
... jeden ansprechen kann...
... Filipp, ich habe gesagt, es soll gut laufen...
... Alter, ist ja gut...
... morgen KS...
... du verstandest der Bild...
... hier ist die Weste des Spielers...
... darin ein kleiner Lautsprecher verbaut...
...
... er hat jetzt hier einen Fehler geschmissen...
... normalerweise würde die App jetzt abstürzen...
... beim Programmieren sitzt das Problem...
... vor dem Bildschirm...
... normalerweise würde die App jetzt abstürzen...
... nur wenn es in C++ programmiert ist...
... wie sieht denn das aus...
... von den Einrückungen, Leute...
... ich sehe da keine Klammern...
... könnte das...
... für Python, es ist ein bisschen viel...
... ein bisschen komisch gestaffelt...
... was ist denn das, jemand eine Ahnung...
... rein von der...
... kann man nicht wirklich gut erkennen, gell...
... meint ihr, das ist HTML...
... das sieht, finde ich...
... nicht so sehr wie HTML aus...
... wir haben leider das Problem...
... dass die Plätze gesperrt sind...
... es ist Druck da, aber...
... ich kann damit sehr gut umgehen, auf jeden Fall...
... es ist Druck da, nice...
... ich bin der Chef der Spur und Geschäftsführer eines Sporttechnologie Startups...
... und wir wollen unser Produkt nächste Woche releasen...
... das heißt wir wollen eine App in den App Store bringen...
... da ist sehr viel zu tun...
... und ob wir das schaffen...
... dann erfahrt ihr in diesem Video...
... die Teilanpassung brauchst, wenn überhaupt...
... und nicht noch voll in der...
... ich bin jetzt schon seit 2 Stunden hier...
... und es ist schon einiges schiefgegangen...
... zuerst ist es Schneekaus hier in Jena...
... und in der Umgebung...
... das heißt, einige Mitarbeiter...
... unter anderem...
... unser Chef-Engineur für die Hardware...
... konnte heute leider nicht hier mit ins Büro kommen...
... dann...
... steh-Tisch...
... Moment, ist das ein höhenverstellbarer Tisch?
...
... ja, oder?
... aber das ist ein Mini, Mini-Büro...
... Mini-Büro, aber gut, ich meine...
... Startup-Stellz, ja?
... ins Büro kommen, dann...
... gab's vorne einen kleinen Fehler...
... wo die neuesten Änderungen...
... nicht mit der IOS-Version kompatibel waren...
... das konnte man sich lösen...
... das wundert mich aber gar nicht...
... steht halt wie gesagt an...
... die Hälfte der Tickets schaffen...
...
Okay.
Unsere Idee war es ein Kommunikationssystem für den Profisport zu entwickeln.
Philipp!
Ich hab gesagt du sollst tief laufen!
Hast du verstanden, dass der will?
Wir wollen möglich machen, dass der Trainer jeden ansprechen kann und das frei wie er
will.
So mit uns.
Die Idee klingt eigentlich echt cool.
Mich würde allerdings wundern, wenn es das nicht schon gäbe.
Kann er einfach einen Spieler ansprechen, den es betrifft und auch in Gruppen, was
mit unserem Tour besser möglich ist.
Das war unsere Vision.
Hier ist die Weste des Spielers.
Darin ein kleiner Lautsprecher verbaut.
Ich finde die Idee cool, mich würde es nur wundern, wenn es da nicht schon etablierte
Systeme für gibt.
Der kann jetzt entfernt werden, muss es nur noch in seine Weste stecken und dann ist man
ready to go.
Und der kann angesprochen werden.
Die letzte Komponente ist natürlich die App, worum diese heute auch geht.
Da hat der Trainer unter Hand und da kann der Trainer seinen Spieler sehen.
Ich bin hier sowohl als Geschäftsführer im Managementbereich tätig, als auch hier
als CTO auch im operativen Bereich.
Neben meiner Programmiertätigkeit verhandle ich auch mit Investoren, mit Industriepartnern,
mit Lieferanten und natürlich habe ich auch Personalentscheidungsgewalt.
Er steht erstmal dahinter und guckt, dass er ordentlich schafft.
Der macht einen äußerst sympathischen Eindruck.
Der Innenminister.
Da kannst du dich jetzt darüber streiten, ob er sich CTO, CEO, aber ich finde, der macht
einen sympathischen Eindruck.
So eine Struktur, mein Mitgründer, der Philipp, das ist unser Außenminister, der macht Marketing,
Vertrieb, alles diese Themen und alles, was nach innen geht, da bin ich der Ansprechpartner.
Die haben einen BWLer, das reicht schon.
Jetzt ist klar, was wir brauchen, wie es aussehen soll, wie wir es brauchen, das müssen wir
jetzt so verfeinern, dass das Failsafe ist, nennen wir das, das heißt, der Nutzer so wenig
wie möglich Fehler machen kann, die die App für ihn nicht mehr nutzt.
Einfach alles über Skype machen.
Ich zeige euch jetzt, was genau das Problem ist und zwar hier in unserem Live-Modus hat
der Trainer die Möglichkeit, sich individuelle Gruppen zu machen und zwar hier kann er einfach
Spiele auswählen und in eine Gruppe ziehen.
Wenn eine Gruppe jetzt hier gelöscht wird, dann erscheinen die Spieler nicht wieder
in der Spielerniste.
Oh.
Ja, dann müssen sie wohl kündigen und neue Spieler kaufen.
Genau, jetzt habe ich einen Versuch gemacht, was das Problem meiner Meinung nach beheben
könnte.
Das muss ich jetzt testen, dafür spiele ich gerade die App nochmal neu drauf.
Ja, wenn das Testen von iOS-Sachen nicht so abfuckt wäre.
Hält mich wieder an, habe wieder gerade die Daten geladen, jetzt sind wir wieder hier.
Ja Leute, automatisierte Tests kommen dann nach Release, jetzt muss erstmal die App fertig
werden.
Das heißt, die automatisierten Tests kommen nie, aber muss Prioritäten setzen.
Das ist immer noch wichtig, immer die Sachen testen, die funktionieren sollen schon, dass
man die immer mal wieder mittestet, weil oft ist es auch so, dass Änderungen, die man
mit dem Code macht, an einer anderen Stelle was kaputt machen können.
Ich vergleiche das immer gerne mit so einem Jahrmarktspiel, was man vielleicht kennt,
wo man diese Maulwürfe runterhauen muss und wenn man einen Maulwurf runterhaut, erscheinen
manchmal einfach drei neue und genauso ist das auch beim Programmieren.
Jetzt löschen wir diese Gruppe, es sind sechs Spieler hier drin, vier Spieler hier.
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Regressionstesten?
Testing?
Regression?
Wie nennt man das auf Deutsch?
Regressionstests?
Oder gibt es das Wort überhaupt?
Jetzt hier 10er-Schein und es funktioniert immer noch nicht, das heißt, das war schon
mal nicht der Fehler.
Leute, ihr habt den falschen Ansatz, ihr erzählt hier irgendwas von Tests oder Dokumentation
oder Kommentare oder sowas, das ist ganz einfach, ab jetzt muss er einfach fehlerfrei programmieren.
Er hat festgestellt, so geht es nicht und jetzt muss er zu seinem Team gehen und sagen,
ab jetzt machen wir keine Fehler mehr, nächste Woche ist Release.
Und alles, was ihn nicht gefällt, einfach nicht benutzen, das haben wir heute auch gelernt,
einfach nicht benutzen, einfach forehead.
Just do it.
Es sind ja immer einzelne Lines of Code und man muss halt genau da finden, wo der Fehler
entstehen könnte, was da falsch übergeben wird, weil das sind ja alles Variablen, die
halt von dem einen, also hier ziehen wir...
Außerdem, ist das überhaupt in Rust entwickelt?
Jetzt erkennen wir es, also es ist auf jeden Fall kein HTML.
Das funktioniert, du musst nur genug dran glauben, dann funktioniert das vielleicht
auch.
In Rust wäre das wenigstens Blazingly fast.
Was?
Der Bartträger?
Welcher Bart?
Das ist bei ihm so ein ganz normaler Bart.
Alles Variablen, die halt von dem einen, also hier ziehen wir in diesem Fall einen Spieler,
die von der einen Gruppe in die Spielliste zurückgegeben werden müssen und genau das
versuche ich halt im Code zu finden und wenn ich das gefunden habe, dann muss man auch
zwei, dreimal probieren, das ist ein Try and Error Prinzip, um dann zu gucken, welche Änderungen
dann gewirkt hat.
Dann melden wir uns wieder an.
Guter Mann.
Genauso hätte ich es auch gesagt, ohne Scheiß, ich will mich da nicht drüber lustig machen.
Genauso hätte ich es auch gesagt, da muss man dann gucken, welche Änderungen da gewirkt
hat und ich meine das nicht, jebaited, genauso hätte ich es auch gesagt.
Das wäre, das ist ein typischer Satz, den ich hier eins zu eins hätte so im Stream sagen
können.
Müssen wir mal gucken, was gewirkt hat.
Der ist richtig drin, das merkt man.
Gehen wieder auf unseren Screen zurück, auch hier wieder dasselbe Flow wie vorhin, wir
packen wieder ein paar Spieler hier in die Gruppe.
Ich habe vorhin schon gesehen, dass es nicht reagiert hat, an genau der gleichen Stelle.
Ihr sollt euch das auch aufgefallen, das letzte Mal, als er den mittleren Typ selecten
wollte, hat es auch schon gebugged.
Was ist das für eine Sprache, ich habe es jetzt nicht gesehen, wahrscheinlich Swift,
wenn es iOS-Zeug ist.
Hier wieder dasselbe.
Oder sie wollen es rausbringen für Android, Cross-Platform, vielleicht ist es auch eine
JavaScript-Zeug, aber wahrscheinlich Swift.
Objective C ist das?
Meinst du ernsthaft, es gibt sich jemand?
Ja.
Guck, habt ihr es gesehen?
Der mittlere ist immer kaputt oder der Finger knapp nicht.
Wir gehen wieder in die Gruppe, gucken mal, ob das noch läuft, gehen wieder rein und
löschen die Gruppe.
Jetzt habt ihr was gesehen, was auch ab und zu mal vorkommen kann, und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier was eingebaut, was nicht funktioniert, das heißt, er hat jetzt hier einen Fehler
geschmissen.
Normalerweise würde die App...
Das Logo erinnert mich ein bisschen an das Logo vom CT-Magazin.
Die App jetzt abstürzen und ja, das ist wie so oft beim Programmieren sitzt das Problem
manchmal auch vor dem Bildschirm und genau, das muss ich jetzt noch mal...
Pepkack.
Ist das dann Pepkack?
Problem exist between keyboard and chair, nee, between screen and chair oder wie geht
das?
Pepkack?
Dann mache ich hier crazy Programmier-Magic, kurz warten, bis alle Daten geladen sind,
wir wollen hier, dass hier 10 steht, löschen, funktioniert, alle 10 Spieler wieder trennen.
Heute stehen noch 15 Tickets an.
Erst mal eine Runde Football spielen, das ist bestimmt auch ein 24-Team-Job aktuell.
Wenn man was erreicht, dann hat man diese Erfolgserlebnisse, das pusht einen natürlich
auch, man hat aber auch viele schlaflose Nächte, wo man halt einfach übernacht, wie
könnte man das machen, wie könnte man das machen, wie darf man das machen, manchmal
mache ich mitten in der Nacht auf und denke so, so kann ich das lösen, schreibe mir das
auf, schlafe weiter und am nächsten Tag versuche ich das umzusetzen.
Also ich glaube, der macht aktuell nicht viel anderes, als sich um die Firma zu kümmern.
Also es kommen immer ungeplante Sachen, es kommen immer Sachen, die man unterschätzt
hat.
Was meint der erst, was los ist, wenn das Ding released ist, es Leute gekauft haben
und irgendwas nicht funktioniert, Alter, das wird der pure Abfang, man.
Ich habe gesagt, die waren ein größeres Problem, die dann doch nicht so ein großes Problem
wurde und man entwickelt sich Schritt für Schritt mit dem Produkt.
In den Vorlesungen wurde behandelt, wie man theoretisch so Projektmanagement macht und
dann halt in der Praxis wurde das auch umgesetzt.
Solche Praxisprojekte ist auch das, was mir am meisten aus der Uni geholfen hat, überhaupt
erst den Transfer in diesen Arbeitskontext zu schaffen.
Chet, ihr wisst doch überhaupt nicht, ob das nicht doch Cloud-Native ist.
Wir haben jetzt die iOS-App gesehen, die ist bestimmt nicht Cloud-Native.
Wie soll eine iOS-App Cloud-Native sein?
Aber das Backend kann doch durchaus High-IQ, Password, Bullshit, Bingo Cloud-Native sein.
Der Hinsicht Informatik ist es so, dass sich einzelne Module dort sehr lohnenswert waren.
Der Wirtschaftshintergrund, also alles, was ich über Marketing dort gelernt habe oder
über Gesellschaftsform, über Controlling, über Budgetierung, über Buchhaltung, das
sind alles Sachen, die ich auch heute reell anwenden kann.
Ich habe auch Buchhaltung gelernt und es gibt sicherlich noch einige Sachen, die ich
davon könnte.
Ich kann z.B. die Buchhalternase noch, das habe ich schon 500 mal erzählt, aber ich
weiß, dass man linear und dekressiv abschreiben kann, aber ich will damit absolut nichts mehr
zu tun haben.
Heute kommt zusätzlich noch eine Studie auf dem Feld, also mit unseren Sportwissenschaftlern
und das steht dann heute Nachmittag an.
Also es ist wieder alles voller Tickets und wir versuchen wieder so viel wie möglich heute
umzusetzen, damit Freitag alles klargeht.
Hier haben wir unsere Sportwissenschaftler, hier leiten wir das Team von Rami, die sind
genau heute für diese Studie verantwortlich, dort wird eben der Einfluss unseres Systems
auf...
Das Video mit dem Florian gibt es noch nicht, der Florian hat ein bisschen mit YouTube zu
kämpfen gehabt, aber wir machen das demnächst.
Patrick, ehrlich gesagt, bei mir ist es nicht so wie bei euch in dem Umfang, aber genau das
habe ich auch gemacht.
Das erste, als ich damals die Firma gegründet habe, ich meine, es ist eine Ein-Mann-Firma,
aber ich sage es jetzt einfach mal so, als ich die Firma gegründet habe, ist mir ein
Steuerberater gesucht und es fuckt mich jetzt schon ab, wenn ich das einmal im Jahr alles
ausfüllen muss, ja, genau so.
Ich hoffe, dass es mal alles gut läuft mit unserer Planung, was wir in den letzten Wochen
so geplant haben und dann wir auch die erhobenen Ideen bekommen, dann können wir den Trainer
auch wissenschaftlich bewiesen, dass zum Beispiel mit unserem System, können die Trainingseinheiten
leichter durchgeführt werden, wird Zeit gespart und die Spieler werden auch...
Jetzt halt die Frage, ob das den Trainer überzeugt.
Also es ist alles die Frage, wie sie ihm das verkaufen, zumal ja vielleicht der Trainer
gar nicht derjenige ist, das entscheidet.
Okay, was ist die Webseite von denen, okay, Sekunde, machen wir mal kurz auf, coachwhisperer.de.
Okay, die Seite ist definitiv nicht written in Rust Placingly Fast.
Ah, jetzt geht es, okay, accept, oh ja, das sieht sowieso eine typische
Webseite mit, weiß nicht, wie sich das nennt, so diese typische aktuelle Landingpage, die
sieht aus wie ein Sport-BH, ja, ein bisschen vielleicht, ja, das sieht aus wie so eine
typische Landingpage und eigentlich ist die Seite gut, die fühlt sich sehr responsive
an und...
Okay, mal gucken, ob sie responsive ist, lass mal kurz gucken, ob die Seite responsive
ist, die Seite ist halbwegs responsive, die Seite ist vollkommen in Ordnung, das ist mein
Reich, unser IT-Büro, da gehen wir jetzt mal rein.
Sie kommen aus dem Baukosten, ist zwar nicht wild.
Ja, er selber beschreibt seinen Job immer so, dass er für alles verantwortlich ist,
was ein Stecker oder ein Akku hat.
Na ja, wie geht es mir, also ich sage mal so, wir sind so auf der Zielgeraden, für 1000
Wege führen nach Rom sozusagen, also so kleine Stolpersteine gibt es ja immer, aber so, bleibt
spannend, jeden Tag aufregend, ich schalte ja auch zu Hause kaum noch ab, ich träume
manchmal davon, sage ich mal, also wenn ich...
Verstehe, weil ich den ganzen Tag Zeug gemacht habe, träume ich auch manchmal, den übertriebensten
Schwachsinn.
Die ganze Nacht vor der Schaltung gesessen habe, dann verfolgt mich das in meinen Träumen
noch, wo irgendwelche Leitungen langliegen.
Ja, kenne ich, es heißt große Anspannung.
Wir haben für die doch schon die Lösung, Chet, wir sollten uns da wirklich mal als
Consultants anbieten, einfach nicht testen.
Wegen des Tests heute, wegen der Studie, wir haben leider das Problem, dass die Plätze
gesperrt sind, aufgrund des Schneefalls.
Ich habe ihn gefragt, ob wir vielleicht noch eine Halle finden, dass das Testing stattfinden
kann.
Na ja, muss man sagen, also wenn es in der Halle geht, dann ist ja auch gleich die Laufweite
daneben.
Genau, also das wäre halt für unsere Studie super wichtig, dass wir weiterhin testen können
und wir setzen jetzt gerade alles irgendwie daran, dass der Termin heute stattfinden kann,
versprechen können wir es natürlich, können wir es natürlich nicht aktuell.
Es kann ja nicht immer alles glatt gehen, sage ich mal, man ist halt nicht her über
das Wetter und darum muss man einfach konstruktiv bleiben, also es bringt nichts zu verzweifeln.
Das ist auch einer der größten Stärken unseres großen Teams und unserer Firma, wir finden
für alles immer Lösungen.
Die sind dann vielleicht nicht die…
Ich muss das noch überzeugender bringen.
Der Plan A, aber wir finden für alles Lösungen und dass ich das jetzt hier so sagen darf,
das macht mir unglaublich stolz.
Ich glaube ihm das sogar, es klang halt nur nicht so komplett überzeugend.
Der Robot hat jetzt nochmal angerufen, wir finden leider keine Halle für heute, deswegen
müssen wir den heutigen Test leider absagen.
Meint ihr, dass es da wirklich passiert oder es ist gestellt an dem Tag, dass die quasi
man reale Situation filmen können?
Es ist Druck da, es ist Druck da, aber ich kann damit sehr gut umgehen, auf jeden Fall.
Ich arbeite sehr viel, das ist als Gründer, das will ich nicht verheimlichen, als Gründer
ist das immer so, dass man nie die 40 Stunden einhält, also es wird eher 1,5bar für zweifach
so viel, aber ich habe nie Schwierigkeiten, früh aus dem Bett aufzustehen und hierher
zu kommen, weil ich lebe mein Traum.
Ist sein Ding, ja, verstehe ich.
Mit so einer Tastatur könnte ich auch nicht gescheit programmieren, guckt euch mal das
Ding an.
Das ist so eine Mini-Flat-Ding, da stehen die Apple Leute vielleicht drauf, aber ich
mag die gar nicht.
Der Upload hat begonnen, ja klar, weil der Upload jetzt auch irgendwie da mit so einem
Progress-Balken 45 Minuten läuft, man, das war flutsch, oder ist das Ding abgeloadet?
Endlich haben wir es geschafft.
Bäm.
Die App ist hochgeladen, wir freuen uns riesig, jetzt ist sie bei Apple zu...
Ja, die App alleine bringt ja nichts, die Leute müssen ja die Hardware dazu kaufen.
Überprüfung dauert wahrscheinlich jetzt zwei bis drei Wochen, bis sie dann auch für
alle im App-Store erscheint, aber wir haben alles gegeben und jetzt kann sie released
werden.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie das Studium...
Das erste Mal Kundenkontakt, okay Leute, das gucken wir, das gucken wir das erste Mal,
das erste Mal Kundenkontakt, ja, ein Moment, der ja irgendwie einen sehr mitnimmt, ja,
wenn man auf sowas keinen Bock hat.
Kundenkontakt ist das Schlimmste, so End-User, ja, so normaler Kundenkontakt, so in Form
von, ich muss mit dem Telekom-Support telefonieren oder sowas, ist kein Ding.
Ja, finde ich auch, die leben halt aktuell gerade 24-7 für ihr Produkt beziehungsweise
für ihren Laden, das kannst du auch nicht ewig machen.
Gut, das ist ein anderer Punkt, du hast vielleicht recht, kann ich nix zu sagen, das stimmt
schon, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich sind die ratzfatz weg und irgendwie gesellt oder
so dann, ja, also rein aus, von technologischer Seite und was wir da gezeigt haben, fand ich
gegen den Laden komplett in Ordnung.
Außerdem gibt es dann eh einen Day One Patch, sobald die erste Hardware ausgeliefert wird.
Okay, Leute, jetzt ist aber wirklich spät, jetzt muss ich pennen, wir sehen uns morgen.
So, alles klar, bis denn, Leute, macht's gut, see you.